Ihr hört CRE Technikkultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle hier zur 216. Ausgabe von CRE,
Und wenn ich so zurückblättere, was eigentlich,
Hier beliebte Sendungen waren, dann gibt's da so ein auffälliges äh wiederkehrendes Mehm, das irgendwie die Lebensmittel hier immer besonders gut äh ankommen, egal ob's äh Kaffee, Brot oder,
Bier ist,
Da dachte ich mir, bleibe ich doch jetzt einfach mal äh dabei und schlage mal ein weiteres, interessantes Kapitel auf, was sich hier äh förmlich anbietet, nämlich Chilis,
Schärfe und äh eine spezielle Lebensmittelkultur, die sich hier auch da äh hinter abgebildet hat.
Und begrüße erstmal den Volker. Volker Tripp, hallo.
Ja hi.
Wir kennen uns ja eigentlich so aus äh netzpolitischen Zusammenhängen. Das ist ja eigentlich eher so deine äh Primärwelt, sage ich mal.
Aber wie das immer so ist, jeder hat ja dann noch einen im Hinterhof und im Keller irgendwie seine Leichen liegen.
Der Mensch braucht ein Hobby.
Spruch ein Hobby grade in der Netzpolitik ist das ganz gut, wenn man sozusagen sich seinen Frust auch noch irgendwie äh anders kanalisieren kann.
Mhm.
Ja und du bist dann irgendwie äh auf diese kleinen Gemüseeinheiten gekommen.
Jo, so sieht's aus.
Ja das ist äh ich habe da vor ich weiß nicht äh,
Schon schon vor einiger Zeit davon gehört, dass sich da was tut, so, dass es da irgendwie so eine eigene Szene gibt, dass es jetzt auf einmal irgendwie äh hip geworden ist oder wie auch immer man das äh ausdrücken will. Ich weiß nicht, gab's da eigentlich einen besonderen
Anlass oder war das schon immer so und es ist jetzt nur irgendwie auch in Berlin sichtbar geworden, dass ich das dann auch mal merke.
Hm also ich glaube in Deutschland war so richtig scharf Essen eigentlich lange Zeit nicht wirklich weit verbreitet, anders als beispielsweise in den USA ähm,
oder auch in Großbritannien, da gab's eigentlich immer schon glaube ich 'nen über das relativ weit verbreitet eben doch scharf zu essen, vielleicht auch eben durch die Einwanderung und so, die man da hat ähm ja,
bei mir, ich ich selber bin drauf aufmerksam geworden, eigentlich so hm weiß ich nicht, 2tausend9 oder so und zwar vor allen Dingen über YouTube.
Weil ich da auf einmal äh Videos gefunden habe von Leuten, die ähm Chilis Essen vor laufender Kamera.
Das ist wirklich ein unglaublicher Sicht hier, ja.
Und zwar äh komplett, also nicht nur mein kleines Stück, sondern so eine ganze Chili
Und zwar chillig sich noch nie gesehen hatte und von denen ich auch noch nie gehört hatte und als die Reaktion dann gesehen hatte, oh dachte mein Gott, das kann überhaupt nicht sein
Wie scharf soll das denn sein? Ja, ich kannte halt so Peperonis,
Ich kannte vielleicht noch Jalapenos, die man so aus dem Kino von den Nachos und so kennt ähm und und äh aber das, was die da so gegessen haben, das schien irgendwie nicht von dieser Welt zu sein und ähm das fand ich ganz spannend und
habe dann einfach mal ein bisschen bisschen gegraben und ein bisschen gelesen und mich da so ein bisschen reingefuchst in die ganze Sache und habe dann eben festgestellt, tatsächlich, es gibt weltweit so eine,
Chilli Head Szene von Leuten, die eben solche ähm,
scharfen Früchte anbauen, verzehren, damit kochen und eben Videos da drüber machen und ähm Soßen kochen und so und sich das Zeug auch gegenseitig hin und her schicken und so weiter,
Ja und das fand ich ganz interessant. Auf die Art und Weise bin ich dann dazu gekommen, mich da ein bisschen näher mit dem Thema zu befassen und dann auch selber anzubauen und so weiter.
Ist aber auch schon wieder so ein Männerding, ne? Und wie sich so eine ganze äh Chili ins Maul stecken. Weißt du, ich habe ich habe jetzt nur schwitzende Männer gesehen, also keine Ahnung, ob das.
Ja, also wo ich ja, das mag sein, ne, das ist irgendwie so ein,
bei manchen Leuten da irgendwie so ein Macho-Ding so eine Rolle spielt. Es gibt aber auch Frauen in der Szene. Ich würde auch sagen, es sind wahrscheinlich weniger, keine Ahnung, ich kenne ja keine Erhebungen drüber, aber gefühlt würde ich sagen, das sind, glaube ich, deutlich mehr Männer als Frauen. Ähm,
Aber ach ja, manche bezeichnen das auch so als als äh kulinarisches Bungeespringen oder so.
Ja, es hat so was von Mutprobe und so. Ich ich stecke mir das Ding jetzt ins Maul.
Ja, das hat sicherlich am Anfang was von Mutprobe und dann auch so mit Schmerzen aushalten und so, aber tatsächlich äh muss man sagen, das ist halt so eine,
Ebene, die finde ich jetzt aber auch so also die hatten einen begrenzten Reiz.
Ja, ich wollte das jetzt auch gar nicht überbetonen, fiel mir nur so auf, dass es sich eigentlich immer nur Männerschwitzen sehen, aber vielleicht bin ich auch nie falsch.
Ja, also sollen wir mal, wenn wenn es so auf dieser Ebene verbleibt, dann ist das häufig auch so ein,
Proletending, finde ich, war echt einfach auch nicht besonders mag. Das ist dann so auf dieser Ebene von so Currywurst scharf S-Wettbewerben. Meistens bestehen diese Soßen eh nur aus Extrakt, schmecken wie Batteriesäure und ähm weiß ich nicht, hat nichts. Also
für mich jedenfalls relativ wenig dann mit dem zu tun, was so die Faszination Chili ausmacht.
Ja. Was macht denn die Faszination aus?
Also Varianz würde ich mal sagen. Also die, die einfach die die wahnsinnige Bandbreite an Formen, an Farben, an Geschmäckern, auch an unterschiedlichen Arten und Weisen,
wie wie sie brennen. Also der Brand ist nicht nur einfach mehr oder weniger stark, sondern bei den verschiedenen Chilis auch qualitativ ganz unterschiedlich,
und ähm ich finde das sehr überraschend, äh wie unterschiedlich diese Früchte schmecken können, wie unterschiedlich sie brennen und so weiter. Auch der Habitus der Pflanzen, wenn man die aufzieht, ist halt teilweise sehr unterschiedlich und
auch das alles ist, finde ich, sehr interessant. Also ich habe im Zuge der Beschäftigung mit Chilis auch einfach viel so über ähm
Zusammenhänge in der Natur gelernt, wie Pflanzen funktionieren, wie Pflanzen wachsen, warum, wieso, weshalb und ähm also ich fand das insgesamt alles sehr lehrreich, muss ich sagen.
Ja, also du hast dich da ein bisschen äh eingehend damit beschäftigt. Würde mich natürlich jetzt erstmal interessieren, wo,
von von welchem ähm Pflanzenevolutionsteil,
brechen wir den jetzt hier eigentlich? Also ich frage mich ja immer, was was ist denn da eigentlich so die Urpflanze äh davon? Ist das irgendwie die Paprika oder ist es die Chili oder haben die beide wieder gemeinsame Vorfahren, die es heute schon gar nicht mehr so gibt?
Und wo kommt das überhaupt her mit der Schärfe?
Ja, also Chilis sind Nachtschatten gewechselt, das heißt sie sind relativ eng verwandt mit Tomaten oder auch mit Physalis, ähm aber auch mit Kartoffeln und äh wie eben all diese Pflanzen auch, kommen die Chillis ursprünglich aus Südamerika,
sind eben durch Kolumbus hierher gebracht worden und haben sich von da aus dann weiter über die Welt verbreitet. Die die ursprüngliche Chili ist eigentlich ein sehr kleine,
unscheinbar aussehende Beere. Tillies sind nämlich tatsächlich anders als viele Leute behaupten sind keine Schoten. Es sind tatsächlich Beeren.
Die Ur-Chili ist wirklich so eine kleine, runde Beere,
wenn man sie in den Mund nimmt, einmal kurz knallt's einmal, dann ist einmal kurz sehr scharf und dann ist es eigentlich auch schon wieder vorbei.
Und die kommt aus Mexiko oder was.
Ähm nee, wie kommt eher aus dem Bereich Peru, Bolivien ähm und äh,
Ob's die jetzt heute in der ganz ursprünglichen Form, wie sie wohl vor mehreren tausend Jahren entstanden ist, äh noch gibt, ist eine Frage,
eher nicht. Es gibt aber sehr so seltene Sorten und Wildsorten, zum Beispiel Eksemium heißt eine und das sind so sehr kleine ähm Beeren erst in diese,
Apfelgrün und reifen dann so dunkel ab. Ähm genau und die sind,
glaube ich immer noch relativ ähnlich sagt man jedenfalls so wie diese Urchilis, also ne knallen einmal sehr scharf auf der Zunge und aber halten nur sehr sehr kurz an. Und das ist so die Urchi und daraus haben sich eigentlich alle,
anderen Sorten entwickelt, unter anderem auch die Paprika. Die Paprika ist auch tatsächlich eine Züchtung, die man,
eben aus die aus Chillis hervorgegangen ist, bei der man eben einfach die Schärfe komplett rausgezüchtet hat. Und ähm genau, deswegen also Chilis und Paprikas, das ist eigentlich dasselbe.
Okay. Das ist äh also im Prinzip geht's aber wir reden hier sozusagen über eine eine Heritage, die sich im Wesentlichen Südamerika irgendwie aufgefunden hat. So in anderen Ländern gab's,
Jetzt nicht so unmittelbar, ich meine zum Beispiel auch so Südostasien ist ja nun auch dafür bekannt, gerne scharf zu essen. Was wo haben die ihre Schärfe her, haben die letzten Endes auch aus Südamerika.
Ja klar, das ist alles. Das ist tatsächlich über Kolumbus und von da aus in den Rest der Welt. Also weiter Richtung Osten und auch noch weiter Richtung Süden. Und es kommt tatsächlich ursprünglich nur aus Südamerika.
Sehr interessant. Wie haben die sich denn dann vorher ernährt.
Ja offenbar ohne.
Und und und sind die die Chili die Einzige, die überhaupt so eine Schärfe mit sich bringt.
Diese Art von Schärfe ja. Ich meine, also man kennt ja den Pfeffer, den ganz normalen, das ist aber Piperin, das ist ein anderer Stoff, das ist nicht Capsaicin,
Dann gibt's eben auch noch diese Schärfe aus Meerrettich und es gibt auch noch die Schärfe aus Senf, aber das sind äh dann jeweils immer ganz eigene Stoffe, eigene Öle und das
Capsaicin oder die Capsacinoide, das sind dann mehrere unterschiedliche Stoffe. Ähm die gibt's so nur in Chilis tatsächlich.
Okay und jetzt auch hier so so typische äh Würzsoßen, hier so Samba Oleg und so weiter. Das ist dann auch alles Chili so.
Das ist alles Chili, genau.
Das heißt, das gibt's auch alles erst seit ein paar 1hundert Jahren quasi und die einzigen, die da vorher mit Spaß hatten, waren so die Peruaner.
Peruaner, Boliviana, genau, also in der Gegend, vor allem es gab in Südamerika, auch in Brasilien und so ähm gab's Chilis etwas andere Sorten, aber eigentlich so als Ursprungsland gilt vor allen Dingen Bolivien und Peru.
Olivien und Pyro und,
Jetzt ist ja nicht so, dass die wahrscheinlich äh losgegangen sind und gleich äh zufällig Bären gefunden haben.
Sondern das war ja dann wahrscheinlich auch schon in kultureller Anwendung. Das dürfte ja dann wahrscheinlich von den indigenen Völkern auch schon so,
Teil der Essenskultur gewesen sein. Und weiß man warum, also.
Ja, man weiß jedenfalls, was die da so mitgemacht haben.
Weil weil es ist ja eigentlich in der eine Abwehrmethode, oder.
Genau, das muss man sagen. Also das ist vielleicht ganz interessant, dass Capsaicin ähm vielleicht ganz kurz dazu, bevor wir dann zu diesem kulturellen nochmal kommen. Also das Capsaicin gaukelt dem Gehirn eigentlich eine Verbrennung vor, ne? Scharf ist äh an.
Weil es triggert die selben Sensoren.
Genau, also scharf ist kein Geschmack, sondern tatsächlich eine Schmerz oder noch genauer eine Temperaturempfindung. Und auf der Zunge gibt es bestimmte Rezeptoren, die sogenannten Notizzeptoren, ja, das sind einfach Schmerzrezeptoren und die werden durch das Capsaicin chemisch aktiviert
Eigentlich würden die aktiviert, wenn man irgendwie was Heißes auf die Zunge bekommt.
Und die werden jetzt eben chemisch aktiviert, sodass das Gehirn annimmt, aha, da liegt eine Verbrennung vor und jetzt ergreift's Gegenreaktion,
Also es erhöht zum Beispiel die Adrenalinausschüttung. Es erhöht auch die Serotoninausschüttung, also das Glückshormon sozusagen, damit man jetzt diese Verbrennung besser aushalten kann.
Und gleichzeitig versuchst du natürlich den Körper abzukühlen und aktiviert deswegen ähm den Schwitzapparat sozusagen. Genau, deswegen fängt man eben an zu schwitzen und einem wird warm.
Man wird auch merken, also zum Beispiel diese erhöhte Serotonin-Sekretion merkt man auch, wenn man sehr scharf ist, zum Beispiel in den Fingern, wenn man so ein Kribbeln in den Fingern dann bekommt dadurch und in den Händen, ja? Das das ganz typische Folge von dieser,
Plötzlich einen hohen Serotonieausschüttung. Man merkt auch, wenn der Schmerz dann zurückgeht, dass ich so eine Erleichterung in einem breit mache. Die die eben auch tatsächlich so auf das Serotonin zurück zu,
Dass also manche Leute nennen das auch das Chili High, also das passiert wirklich, wenn man eigentlich bis an seine Schärfegrenze oder darüber hinaus,
ran ist. Das ist dann erstmal recht unangenehm, aber ab dem Zeitpunkt, in dem das der Brand dann nachlässt, merkt man wirklich einen ganz tiefes Entspannungsgefühl. Also ist jetzt nicht so von wegen ist so schön, wenn der Schmerz nachlässt. Man hat sich mitm Hammer auf den Fingernagel gehauen oder so. Das ist schon anders. Also das ist schon durchaus ganz angenehm.
Meine Syndrom wie Ecstasy und so weiter, die gehen ja auch extrem auf den Serotonin-Spiegel, also das ist im Prinzip der selbe Mechanismus, der da getriggert wird, wenn auch durch äh andere Auslöser.
Genau und mit einem anderen Vorlauf sozusagen. Also das ist eben dann nicht nur angenehm, ne? Aber ähm genau, aber es ist also tatsächlich fühlt sich das eigentlich ganz ganz gut an. So, wo waren wir jetzt gerade stehen geblieben?
Na ja, ich habe und dass das ja eigentlich eine.
Abwehrreaktion ist.
Ja beziehungsweise das ist ja erst mal eine Schutzmechanismus der Pflanze wahrscheinlich ist, um nicht gepresst zu werden. Aber es macht ja eigentlich keinen Sinn, weil die Früchte sind doch meistens eigentlich für für Samen, Transport gedacht.
Genau, ja richtig, also der ja der Trick ist folgender, scharf sind Chilis für Säugetiere, aber nicht für Vögel
Und Säugetiere und Vögel haben unterschiedlichen Verdauungsapparat. In dem Verdauungsapparat von Säugetieren werden die Kerne, also die Samen, einfach
die werden schlicht und er zersetzt, ja? Aber nicht im Verdauungsapparat von Vögeln. Im Gegenteil, der Verdauungsapparat von Vögeln, also der der der Darm und die Bakterien im Darm von Vögeln führen dazu, dass die Schale der Samen nur ganz leicht angeraut wird
dadurch aber später aufnahmefähiger ist für Feuchtigkeit und die Vögel außerdem überbrücken in der Regel große Distanzen, indem sie fliegen, also sie fressen eine Chilischote,
Fliegen irgendwo anders hin und lassen die dann da wieder fallen mit äh gleich zusammen mit Dünger und wenn dann Wasser drauf kommt, kann das Wasser leichter eindringen in die Samen und dadurch keimen die dann tatsächlich besser. Das heißt also im Grunde sind Chilis und nimmt man jedenfalls an,
angepasst auf die Ausbreitung über Vögel, aber eben gerade nicht über Säugetiere und das scheint so der Grund zu sein und eigentlich alle solche Tiere lassen auch automatisch von Chillis die Finger
bis auf den Menschen. Ist keine kleine Lücke in der Theorie würde ich sagen.
Ja, weil der Mensch äh begriffen hat, dass dass diese Nebeneffekte auch andere positive Effekte haben.
Ja und dass sie steuerbar sind. Also ich glaube, das ist so so der Punkt. Für Tiere ist das vielleicht nicht so klar, dass wenn man weniger nimmt, ähm dass es dann weniger stark ist und dass man's halt regulieren kann und so und dass der Mensch kann das eben sehr genau machen. Nehme ich mal an, das ist der Grund. Ich weiß aber auch nicht genau.
Ja es geht ja auch immer so die These, wenn man sich fragt, warum jetzt ausgerechnet in den Asien so gerne scharf gegessen wird, dass jetzt insbesondere da diese Schweißbildung, dass das irgendwie von
Vorteil sein soll, in den heißen Temperaturen, ich habe das jetzt noch nicht über einen längeren Zeitraum so überprüfen können, ob das wirklich so ist oder ist das eigentlich nur ein Mytho.
Nee, das stimmt. Also natürlich ist das so, es treibt die die Schweißproduktion in die Höhe und dadurch hat man einen Kühlungseffekt. Das ist ein Kühlsystem, das
also das ist generell in heißen Dingern so. Es gibt noch einen anderen Nebeneffekt ähm dieses Capsaicin der Schärfewirkstoff ähm,
wirkt äh Bakterien tötend äh gegen das Bakterium Heliobacta Pelori. Das ist so ein schraubenförmiges,
was eigentlich fast alle Menschen in ihrem Magen haben, was zum Beispiel zu Magenschleimhautentzündungen führen kann.
Und gerade in Ländern, die eben, wo's generell heißer ist, wo dadurch die Nahrung einfach auch eine höhere Bakterienbelastung aufweist, einfach weil die Bakterien sich bei Höhen hohen Temperaturen schneller vermehren. Da kann eben Kapsel ziehen, kann scharfes Essen dazu beitragen, dass man,
So eben mit Bakterien kontaminiertes Essen einfach besser verträgt.
Ah, also es tötet die nicht unmittelbar ab, sondern.
Also es hindert die jedenfalls an der weiteren Vermehrung wohl und ähm also es führt eben dazu, dass wie gesagt bakteriell belastetes Essen besser vertragen wird
Es gibt aber noch eine ganze Reihe anderer auch medizinischer Anwendungen ähm die also traditioneller medizinischer Anwendung für Chillies beispielsweise ähm wurde,
bei den indigenen Völkern in Südamerika, also bei den Inka beispielsweise ähm er wurden Chilis verwandelt gegen Zahnschmerzen.
Denn wenn man also hingeht und man man schmiert sich so also man schneidet einen Chili auf, man schmiert sich die aufs Zahnfleisch, hat das tatsächlich einen betäubenden Effekt. Also es fängt nicht an zu brennen, sondern für,
gewisse Zeit, ne, eine relativ kurze Zeit ist das ähnlich wie mit Nelken oder so. Das hat dann einfach es betäubt einen Effekt, weil die Schmerzweiterleitung dadurch unterdrückt wird.
Das ist eine traditionelle Anwendung, wie gesagt, gegen Zahnschmerzen und bei dem Inka äh beziehungsweise ich glaube eher bei den Maja, also eher in Mittelamerika dann
wurde das auch verwendet, wurde Chili verwendet in Zusammenhang mit Kakao, also diese die klassische klassische Kakao ist ja eigentlich sehr sehr bitter und der wurde dann gewürzt mit ähm Chili und das gibt's ja hierzulande auch mittlerweile wieder diese Kombination.
Schokolade und Chili und das ist eigentlich so die ganz die ganz klassische Anwendung eigentlich tatsächlich, die Kombination mit Kakao. Mhm.
Wenn man jetzt irgendwie.
Nee, wie gesagt, das ist eigentlich also die, die, die, die, die traditionelle Anwendung so bei den, bei den Völkern, die eigentlich ursprünglich äh Chilis benutzt haben, ist also eine der der typischen ist jedenfalls mit Kakao.
Hatten also als Getränk dann aber. Mhm.
Ja, klar, genau. Mhm.
Weil hier würde man jetzt einen Kakao eher an Schokolade äh äh Kakaobutter sozusagen denken.
Nee, nee, genau. Nee, da hat man diese dieses Getränk, aber wie gesagt, das hat, glaube ich, dieser traditionelle Kakao hat nicht so wirklich viel zu tun mit dem ähm Kakao, den wir so kennen.
Bei uns halt im Wesentlichen aus Zucker besteht und da ein bisschen hinaus Kakao. Also ein ganz anderer Bitterstoff, der da wahrscheinlich äh normalerweise am Start ist. Ja.
So, das heißt, also Captain ist im Wesentlichen eigentlich ein ein Schutzmechanismus. Der Pflanze,
vermutlich darauf gepolt, dass man gerne von Vögeln gefressen werden will, um eben die Ausbreitung zu äh fördern und Säugetiere wollte man nicht dabei haben, weil die laufen nicht weit genug. Keine Ahnung.
Zersetzen sich in ihrem Verdauungssystem.
Ja okay, das heißt, die die werden dann komplett aufgelöst sozusagen. Aber.
Genau, dann damit gibt's keine Verbreitung.
Aber die Säugetiere mögen's eh nicht, weil's schon irgendwie in den Schleimhäuten äh problematisch äh ist und später auch und deswegen lassen sie die,
eher in Ruhe, dann kamen irgendwie die Menschen, haben gesagt, na ja, das ist zwar irgendwie unangenehm, aber unangenehm, kann man irgendwie oskalieren und wenn man das irgendwie mit äh Erhitzungen und anderen äh Dingen äh kombiniert oder mit anderen Sachen halt überhaupt generell äh kombiniert, dann wird's irgendwie,
schon wieder ganz interessant und wird dann wahrscheinlich auch verschiedene rituelle Bedeutungen erfahren haben oder weiß man wahrscheinlich gar nicht so genau.
Weiß ich nicht so genau, aber es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das auch also rituelle Verwendung gefunden hätte, ja.
So und so ist dann halt der Olde Columbus quasi draufgekommen so da ist irgendwie was zu holen. Da gibt's eine Pflanze, die kennen wir so nicht.
Schärfe, wer weiß wo's zu äh wo's gut ist, packen wir mal ein Schiff und das gehörte dann zu diesen zwanzig Kisten mit Sonderkram.
Aus der neuen Welt.
Aus der neuen Welt. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, wie das irgendwie damals wohl gewesen sein muss. Meine Kolumbus, meine gibt's nicht viel zu feiern im Wesentlichen sind die rübergefahren und haben erstmal alle umgebracht so und äh.
Der Bodenschätze bemäch.
Bodenschätze äh und eben auch der Pflanzenwelt äh mächtig. Nichtsdestotrotz war das ja dann sagen wir mal eine Transformation äh der,
Menschheitsentwicklung als solcher, gerade eben weil dann auf einmal so viel Dinge in die alte Welt kamen, die es halt so bisher nur in der neuen Welt gab oder zumindest nur dort so bisher gefunden wurden.
Und äh das betrifft ja viele Pflanzen und die Kartoffel wird ja dann im Prinzip auch dazu, ne?
Im Prinzip, die Kartoffel gehört dazu, der Mais, die Tomate, die Physalis, also die Physalis wäre irgendwo Tabak, ne, alles so Pflanzen, die ähm aus Südamerika.
Ja, all die ganzen.
Guten Sachen.
Die guten Sachen kommen aus Südamerika,
Ja so und das kann dann aber in Form dieser äh kleinen Chilibeere. Das war dann wahrscheinlich alles, was es gab.
Genau
Also erst mal, es gab noch nicht diese diese wahnsinnige Formen und Farbvielfalt, die man eben heute hat. Es gab wohl ursprünglich auch schon unterschiedliche Sorten. Oft waren diese Wildsorten nur auf die waren so endemisch für relativ kleine Räume. Also die gab's wirklich nur in in relativ
eng begrenzten Gebieten und dann gab's leichte Variationen, aber im Prinzip waren das alles diese kleinen scharfen Beeren.
Und dann ist man eben hingegangen, hat die hier auch kultiviert und ähm angebaut und äh da muss man wissen, Chilis sind untereinander relativ leicht zu kreuzen,
Und ähm sind also ohnehin sagen wir mal variieren relativ leicht. Ne?
Weil sie letzten Endes jetzt alle von der selben Pflanze kommen oder warum?
Nein, nein, sondern wenn ich wenn ich verschiedene Chiliarten miteinander kombiniere, es geht relativ gut verschiedene Chilisorten miteinander zu kombinieren.
Ja gut, aber die haben ja alle denselben Ursprung jetzt quasi vor ein paar hundert Jahren noch gehabt.
Das Jahr, aber ich sagte ja gerade auch in Südamerika sind die in in einzelnen Räumen, also Gebieten Regionen, nicht jetzt großartig, die müssen noch nicht mal groß sein diese Region, relativ kleine Abschnitte gibt's leichte genetische Unterschiede zwischen,
Wenn man die wiederum rekombiniert miteinander, dann ergibt sich eben wiederum.
Und das ist nicht generell so jetzt bei Pflanzen.
Ich glaube, das ist bei weitem nicht bei allen Pflanzen so, dass sie so einfach zu kreuzen sind und dass das tatsächlich funktioniert, ja.
Dass dass es bei Chillis eben relativ einfach. Das ist auch einer der Gründe, weswegen es so viel Spaß macht, die anzubauen, weil man halt sehr leicht ähm auch zu zu so ganz neuen Formen und so kommen kann, die man so noch nicht kennt. Aber jedenfalls genau, was dann passiert.
Mhm. Aber das das ist dann im Wesentlichen Europa gemacht worden. Das war so, sagen wir mal, in Südamerika noch gar nicht ein Thema.
Nö die, weil da hat man die eigentlich nicht äh kultiviert oder angebaut, sondern einfach die, das waren Wildpflanzen, die man da benutzt hat. Also da ist sind eigentlich Chillis als solche eigentlich noch nicht als Kulturpflanze vorgekommen. Das ist
erst hier entstanden.
Die Briten sind schuld.
Vielleicht auch dir oder die Portugiesen oder die Spanier, ich weiß es nicht
Aber genau, aber also das es hat sich eigentlich wohl generell erst in Europa so entwickelt, dass man eben Chillis angebaut hat und dabei sind auch eine ganze Reihe eigentlich bei bei dieser Reise so von Chillis um den Globus und eine ganze Menge Mythen und Missverständnisse entstanden, die sich
Auch teilweise noch in den Bezeichnungen niederschlagen. Ähm heutzutage gibt es eigentlich unter,
den,
könnte man sagen,
Die eben mit lateinischen Begriffen bezeichnet werden.
Bacatum, Kapsikum
und. Die die bekannteste Gruppe ist eigentlich die um, also die
jährliche Kapsikum. Dazu gehören eben zum Beispiel Paprikas, aber eben auch die Peperoni, die man ausm Supermarkt kennt oder die Jalapeno.
Und ähm diese Bezeichnung kommt eben daher,
Dass die Chilipflanze eigentlich maximal Temperaturen von Plus äh Minimaltontemperaturen von plus fünf Grad verträgt.
Und da drunter gehen die eigentlich kaputt. Also wenn die Umgebungstemperatur unter 5 Grad sinkt, dann gehen die Pflanzen häufig ein. Unter null Grad gehen sie auf jeden Fall ein
Sondern hat man sich hier halt angebaut im Freiland und im Winter sind diese Pflanzen eingegangen und dann dachte man aha, das sind einjährige Pflanzen.
Weil die gehen ja offenbar nach einer Saison kaputt und tatsächlich sind Chilis aber mehrjährig, die können,
20, 25 Jahre alt werden, unter ähm guten Bedingungen und ähm,
In ihrer eigentlichen Heimat, in Südamerika wachsen die das ganze Jahr durch und die produzieren auch das ganze Jahr durch,
Und nur hier eben im Winter gehen die in der Regel kaputt, es sei denn, man holt die dann rein, aber wenn man die draußen anbaut, ähm gehen sie dann leider ein, ne? Und daher kommt jedenfalls das Missverständnis, dass man ursprünglich mal dachte, Chilis sei ein einjährige Pflanzen.
Was sie eben tatsächlich gar nicht sind.
Daher der Name Anno.
Genau, daher der Name Anno.
Das Jahr. Mhm.
Genau und oder.
Spanischer Pfeffer nennt man das eigentlich, ne.
Ja, also da gibt eine der vielen Bezeichnungen. Ähm
die Kapsel Kompinense, ne, eigentlich die die chinesischem hieß so,
weil ich glaube Marco Polo die mal äh von der Reise mitgebracht hat und man halt dachte ähm das sei also weil die eben in China diese Sorte, ähm weil man die dort gefunden hat, äh hat man gedacht, ah die kommt auch ursprünglich daher,
Nein, war eben auch nur eine eine genetische Variation von anderen Sorten, die ursprünglich aus Südamerika kamen.
Aber man hat sie eben in China gefunden und darum chinesische genannt, hat aber gar nichts damit zu tun.
Ja. Das sind dann diese Habaneros.
Zum Beispiel, genau. Also Jabanero und die ganzen karibischen Sorten ähm also zum Beispiel oder oder und solche Sachen, die kommen also das sind alles chinesische Sorten.
Da gibt's ja so richtig noch mal so Namen für die einzelnen Sorten. Was war das andere? Trinid da Scorpion und?
Ja klar, also da ja genau, also Trainee Dead Scorpion oder Seven Pot heißt eine also sieben Topf.
Oder Scotch Bonnet vielleicht.
Genau, die Scott-Bonnet ist auch eine relativ bekannte oder hier die Jamaken Hot Chocolate, die ich hier auch mitgebracht habe.
Da blicke ich schon die ganze Zeit mit einem gewissen Respekt. Auf diese Tüte.
Auch ja, dass die sind so Habernero-Scharf, die sind jetzt nicht so. Also die hier der ich habe noch so eine so eine vietnamesische, die ist richtig gemein hier, die ist böse. Das zeige ich dir. Da können wir gleich mal drücken.
Okay, also das sind dann sozusagen alles ähm Ausprägungen dann auch die,
Weiß nicht, diese diese scharfen Dinger, die sehen auch alle so wulstig aus, ne. Also man ist ja immer diese,
Ist immer diese diese relativ ähm ja einfachen runtergezüchteten Paprikas äh gewöhnt, aber diese Chilipflanzen, die sind dann teilweise haben die so ganz gefährliche,
Krümmungen und Wölbungen, die einem schon eine ganze Menge Respekt.
Wenn die wenn die unten so ein wenn die unten noch so einen kleinen Haken dran haben, dann sind sie in der Regel besonders böse.
So ein paar Sorten, die haben noch unten so einen kleinen Auswuchs, so hakenförmig kommt er raus ähm das kann dann zum Beispiel so eine Trainig der Scorpion sein, die schon so
Beim 1,4 Millionen Scoville liegen kann. Scoville ist eine Einheit für die Schärfe. Können wir gleich nochmal drüber sprechen. Es gibt aber eben noch eine andere Sorte, ähm die ein amerikanischer Züchter namens Ed Curry vor einigen Jahren,
mal rausgebracht hat die nennt sich Carolina oder,
Und ähm die kann bis zu zweieinhalb Millionen Scoville haben. Das also deutlich schärfer als Pfefferspray der Polizei.
Das ist auch so eigentlich also das der arbeitet zusammen mit einer Uni in Sachen Krebsforschung, weil
äh bei dem Capsaicin zur Zeit eben an an den äh krebseindämmenden Eigenschaften forscht und dazu braucht man eben Chillis, die in möglichst hohen Gehalt haben und der hat dann mal speziell,
So für die Zusammenarbeit mit der Uni so eine Sorte gezüchtet, die also ich finde nicht konsumierbar ist, weil das.
Diese California Ripa oder.
Äh ähm genau, Carolina Reeper.
Carolina Reeper. Ich glaube, da habe ich mal gesehen, wie sich das hier mal in den Mund gesteckt hat. Der war dann auch wirklich 5zehn Minuten am Arbeiten.
Ja das also ich äh also und ich glaube das wäre bei jemandem so, der der sehr geübt ist wenn man das nicht gewohnt ist, wird man wahrscheinlich,
also kriegt man wahrscheinlich einen Kreislaufkollaps oder so.
Das kann schon sein, dass also, dass einer so mitnimmt und das Herz da plötzlich so schnell schlägt und so, dass man schlicht in der Greifenkreis auf Kollaus bekommt. Also das würde ich keinem empfehlen, eine Caroliner Reeper einfach so zu essen. Das ist gar keine gute Idee.
At home. Aber machen wir noch mal kurz deine Sorten äh Übersicht äh fertig. Dann hat sie noch äh genannt.
Heißt das einfach. Das sind die die meisten Sorten davon kommen äh
Auch heute noch aus Südamerika, gibt's also, gibt's auch ein paar andere, aber die meisten davon kommen aus Südamerika, viel aus Brasilien, so Regenwaldsorten sind es oft, ähm die mit Achi.
Also die die das Wort Achi im Namen tragen, was eigentlich nur das das ähm so in Südamerika gebräuchliche Wort für Chilli ist.
Also geschrieben A J I mhm.
Die Engländer sagen immer Argi dazu, aber ich glaube eigentlich heißt Achi.
Auf Spanisch ist.
Genau,
Und ähm genau, die also diese Bacatonsorten ähm finde ich, zeichnen sich eigentlich fast alle dadurch aus, dass die so einen leicht säuerlichen Geschmack haben und der Brand ist eigentlich immer vor allen Dingen sehr stark vorne auf der Zunge.
Bei bei den Chinensesorten, da ist er eigentlich überall im Mund, aber so wie ganz wie tausend Stecknadeln.
Bei den Anumsorten ist es eher sehr schneidend und also bisschen, dass in einem einer von der Seite in die Zunge beißt oder so und äh bei den Baggertumsorten ist es meistens so äh nur vorne auf der Zungenspitze und die ist so ganz leicht betäubt.
Aber unendlich ist die, ist an der Zungenspitze mit den Sensoren nochmal irgendwas anders.
Ne, das liegt daran, äh ich sage dir eben schon, es gibt nicht nur das Capsaicin, sondern es gibt Capsacinoide. Und zwar zwölf unterschiedliche, also das sind
verschiedene Substanzen, Capsaicin, Homocapsaisin, die Hydro Homo-Capseycin und so weiter und so fort und je nachdem wie diese Substanzen im Einzelnen zusammengesetzt sind,
Also in welchen Mengen Verhältnissen in der äh in der Frucht vorkommen, brennt es halt auch unterschiedlich. Und das ist eben von Sorte zu Sorte verschieden und dann hängt's noch mal ein bisschen von den Anbaubedingungen ab.
Ja, also wie stark eben denn ähm die Kapuzinoidel da wirklich konzentriert sind. Aber genau, im Prinzip hängt's halt davon ab, wie sind diese Stoffe verteilt in der Pflanze und davon hängt eben ab,
wie fühlt sich der Brand an,
Ne und ähm also ich finde das ganz schön. Die eignen sich zum Beispiel häufig gut für Salate, so finde ich, die diese ähm,
Sorten aber es gibt auch also zum Beispiel in Peru ist so die die bekannteste.
Chili so von allen, äh die Achi Amarillo, so mit Handy auch
Da sehr viel kochen. Ähm Arigalina ist zum Beispiel so ein Gericht ähm so so Hühnchen in so einer knatschgelben Soße. Sieht auch total lecker aus, schmeckt auch total lecker und das kriegt halt sein seine seine Charakteristik eigentlich durch diesen Geschmack von diesen Achit Chillis und,
Also in Südamerika wie gesagt werden die sehr gut sehr gerne eingesetzt. Ähm dann gibt's noch äh die ich finde das sind eigentlich die gehören so mit zu den interessantesten,
Chilisorten, die werden noch Rokoto genannt,
Ähm sehen so ein bisschen aus wie eine Mischung aus einem Apfel und einer Tomate. Sind sehr, sehr dickwandig und werden in der äh auch in Südamerika
Bolivien zum Beispiel gerne ausgehöhlt und gefüllt gegessen. Und was sie dann in Bolivien teilweise machen, das ist ganz witzig, weil diese Rokotus teilweise doch eine echt heftige Schärfe haben können.
Die werden ausgehöhlt und dann in Milch eingelegt, weil die Kapsacinoide fettlöslich sind. Das heißt, die binden sich dann an das Fett in der Milch
Dann nimmt man die Rekorde wieder raus, kippt die Milch weg, macht neue Milch rein, legt die Rote wieder rein, wiederholt diesen Vorgang einfach ein paar Mal.
Sagen die Schärfe ein bisschen raus.
Genau und dann nimmt man so die ganz harte Kante von dieser Schärfe und dann wird es halt gefüllt mit Fleisch oder Reis oder irgendwie je nachdem, was man halt möchte, ne? Und und dann wird das so gebacken.
Das heißt, deswegen ist einerseits die Schokolade auch ein dankbarer Partner, weil sich da die Schärfe gut äh auflöst.
Aber es stimmt auch, dass Milch tatsächlich auch hilft, wenn man dann so das Gefühl hat, jetzt geht's gar nicht mehr ein bisschen Milch trinken.
Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall. Das hilft halt gut. Also im, ne, die, die, die Schärfe bindet sich an, an, an das Fett,
Und dadurch, wenn man's eben dann danach weggibt das Fett, der ist wie in dem Fall, ist dann halt auch, dass ich raus. Die Chili ist insgesamt weniger scharf. Wenn ich die Schärfe bereits im Mund habe und ich kippe dann irgendwas Fettiges nach, ob das jetzt Milch ist, kann aber auch Joghurt sein, kann Speiseeis sein.
Egal, irgendwann kann auch Öl sein oder Butter von mir aus. Ähm dann wird das auch so sein. Die Schärfe bindet sich daran, man schluckt dann runter, dann hat man's halt im Magen, aber eben nicht mehr ja das, ich meine, das kann auch unangenehm sein, aber das brennt dann halt jetzt erstmal nicht mehr so akut
Ähm allerdings, das wird natürlich nie komplett weg
gewaschen, ja? Deswegen, es bleibt dann da und dann sobald diese dieser Effekt dann weg ist, wenn man, wenn man die Milch runtergeschluckt hat, dann kommt halt auch
Die Schärfe wieder zurück. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen, die man machen kann, also Zucker kann auch helfen, also vor allen Dingen, wenn man ähm,
Mit Chilli ist so umgegangen ist, mit denen gearbeitet hat,
Die aufgeschnitten hat und so weiter. Man hat äh dieses Öl ähm an den Fingern, an den Händen oder unter den Fingernägeln, das kann sehr sehr unangenehm sein. Da hilft, wenn man sich die Hände mit zehnprozentiger Zuckerlösung wäscht
Das Ganze ist also macht man auch oft so, einfach weil das hilft, um Öle abzuwaschen, ja? Es gibt in der Industrie gibt's auch so Seifen, so zehnprozentige Zuckerseifen im speziell, wenn man so irgendwie Tätigkeiten hat, bei denen man schnell irgendwie Öl oder so auf die Hände kriegt, um es abzuwaschen, geht das ganz gut.
Und ähm was auch geht, ist äh Limettensaft zum Beispiel. Also es hilft auch ähm Säure, hilft auch ein bisschen zumindest gegen.
Also jetzt auf den Händen oder auch im Mund.
Auf auf den Händen zum Abwaschen aber auch im Mund. Beides, ja. Also es geht beides ganz gut.
So, jetzt fahren wir ja ein bisschen eigentlich gerade bei den äh Sorten. Ich gucke noch mal. Also wir hatten diese Anlumen, wir hatten Chinense, wir hatten Bacatum und Pubessence.
Genau und es fehlt noch Food-Tessens.
Protessens.
Also die fruchtige, aber ähm das sind meistens so Zier-Chilis. Ähm,
Also die diese Sorten, die man so kennt, die meisten so klein und rund oder so ein bisschen spitz sind ähm das sind oft Protessesorten. Ich glaube, die bekannteste Frodessinssorte ist wahrscheinlich Tabasco.
Also die auch die aus aus der auch diese Würzsoße gemacht wird. Ähm da werden diese Chilis dann geerntet und dann fermentiert ähm in Essig und ähm,
Das ist dann im Grunde diese Soße. Genau, das sind so die bekanntesten Vertreter, denke ich.
Jetzt heißt ja Kapsikum also Kapsikum ist ja eigentlich die Paprika.
Ja ja die die Chili eher würde ich sagen.
Na ja, also Gattung, Paprika, Kapsikum. Sagt Wikipedia.
Ja, ja, ja, wenn man.
Also wir verstehen jetzt unter Paprika was anderes, nämlich diese eine konkrete äh Frucht.
Während man während man ja, also aber auch eben nur in Deutschland, ne sobald man jetzt aus Deutschland rausgeht, also wenn man im Englischen zum Beispiel das Wort Paprika benutzt, meinen die was anderes.
Also das, das, was wir dann als Paprika bezeichnen, bezeichnen im Englischen als Bellpepper und wenn die Peprecare sagen, dann meinen die halt schon diese ungarischen also die schon so ein bisschen schärfer sind, länger und und spitz.
Ja gut, mag sein, aber der der Wissenschaftler der deutsche wissenschaftliche Gattungsname der lateinisch Kapsikum ist,
im Deutschen als Paprika geführt wird. So, deswegen wollte ich das auch grad mal aufdröseln.
Weil wir ja nun eigentlich mit Paprika, die eigentlich ja gezähmt ist wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen was äh untertrieben, ne? Also eine eine äh Frucht, deren man ihre äh,
Herkunft vollkommen ausgetrieben hat sozusagen, ne.
Also da ist halt genau, das ist wie wie Cannabis Ruderalis. Wie Cannabis ohne THC.
Industrie hat sozusagen.
Ja genau, in Industriepaprika
aber das Jahr ist eben weil es mag halt nicht jeder die Schärfe und ähm deswegen gab's eben auch Züchtungen, die weniger oder gar keine Schärfe haben. Das ist ja auch finde ich der Reiz, dass es halt diese diese
unglaubliche Spannbreite gibt von nur ein ganz bisschen pikant bis hin zu unerträglich scharf. Das ist ja auch also krass, dass es einfach diese wahnsinnige Varianz haben kann
finde, ich sage ja vorhin schon, dass eigentlich das, was mich da so einen Aspekt, der mich einfach sehr an Chilis fasziniert.
Ja und dazu kommt natürlich noch dieses fruchtig äh Knackige, was einfach diese Pflanzen ja an sich mitbringen. Das äh hat ja auch was, so also nicht nur so als Beigabe, sondern auch roh Viecher äh das schon immer,
Ähm ganz ganz reizvoll, bin eigentlich auch ein äh Freund der Paprika. Ich habe jetzt so mit Schärfe nicht so ein mega Problem gehabt. Mir hat vor Kurzem,
Wie man genauso eine, so eine Chili äh Schokolade äh zugeschickt so, ne, wo wir ja wahrscheinlich dann so Chili Pulver verwendet wird, ne, also so,
gemahlene Samen, die er dann halt damit in diesen ganzen.
Die Samen nicht eher die die Samen nimmt man eigentlich eher raus.
Die Samen nimmt man raus. Und was, also ja okay, was wird denn dann genommen, um so eine.
Und also wenn du ähm na ja nee, das kann man jetzt übers Radio natürlich nicht so gut hören, aber also wenn man so eine Chili aufschneidet, dann sieht man da innen drin zum einen Samen
Und zum anderen sieht man, das kämen auch von den von den Paprika so so weiße oder gelbliche Wände, die da innen drin langlaufen. Ja? Das ist diese.
Mhm diese Stege.
Stege. Das ist die Plazenta,
Ja und auf der Plazenta sitzen die Samen, so die Plazenta selber, die produziert das Capsaicin. Das ist wirklich scharf. Und die Samen selber, die sind eigentlich gar nicht scharf. Die sind deswegen auch scharf, weil die auf dieser Plazenta sitzen.
Ja, aber die Samen selber sind eigentlich nur bitter und also ich würde die immer eher rausnehmen vorher,
ne? Also weil die jetzt an sich nicht besonders lecker sind und jetzt auch von der Konsistenz nicht so besonders lecker sind und auch bevor ich jetzt zum Beispiel Chillis mahle, versuche ich die die Samen rauszumachen, aber eben die Plazenta drin zu lassen. Wenn man die Plazenta rausmacht, dann nimmt man halt viel von der Schärfe weg
Was bei solchen hier zum Beispiel also bei so Habaneros oder noch schärferen durchaus ganz vernünftig sein kann weil es dann einfach nicht mehr so so super harsch ist, ja.
Aber ähm also es sei denn man möchte das natürlich, ne? Und ähm aber wie gesagt, die Samen würde ich eigentlich immer rausnehmen, weil die also weder besonders lecker schmecken, noch eine schöne Konsistenz haben oder so ähm und eben auch anders als das landläufig immer so ähm
kolportiert wird auch tatsächlich nix zur Schärfe beitragen.
Es bringt uns ja so ein bisschen jetzt auch so dieses, okay, es gibt also viele Sorten,
Die sind jetzt irgendwie unterschiedlich scharf. Die haben so unterschiedliche Ausprägungen, manche sind ein bisschen fruchtiger, manche sind so ein bisschen knackiger. Mal mag man der eigentlichen ähm,
dem eigentlichen Geschmack bisschen auf der Spur sein, teilweise äh geht's auch um die Schärfe oder eine Mischung davon.
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt bist du denn dann an diesen Punkt gekommen, dass du denkst, ey, du willst dir das jetzt mal selber wachsen lassen, weil eigentlich,
Gibt's ja genug. Also man kann ja hier in unserem reichen Land äh in Märkte äh gehen und bekommt ja das ein oder andere, was was hast du da gesucht? Was hat dich da getriggert?
Also zweitausendneun, 210 war das, ehrlich gesagt, noch nicht ganz so, wie das jetzt ist. Also beispielsweise jetzt kann ich hier in Berlin im Supermarkt durchaus auch mal Jalapenos oder Jabaneros kaufen. Das war zu der Zeit eigentlich noch nicht so. Das ist jetzt erst so in den letzten paar Jahren,
zu gekommen nach meiner Beobachtung. Also das ist etwas so so einfach breiter gefächert war, dass man das normal in Supermärkten bekommt, musste man schon suchen eher vorher, würde ich sagen. Und ähm,
es gab eben dann vor allen Dingen so diese normalen Peperonis und so und das war halt einfach,
Bisschen langweilig im Verhältnis zu dem, was ich da vorher gesehen habe. Und dann habe ich mich halt ein bisschen erkundigt und und ein bisschen gesucht und bisschen recherchiert und festgestellt, wow, es gibt ja,
unterschiedlicher Sorten, ja und also mit den unterschiedlichsten Eigenschaften und die sehen ganz unterschiedlich aus und so weiter und so fort und das war dann eigentlich der Trigger. Ich dachte, oh das möchte ich selber mal probieren. Habe dann anfangs tatsächlich.
Überlegt, wie mache ich das genau in in weil in der ersten Saison muss es dann sehr schnell gehen, da habe ich dann mal zurückgegriffen auf so ähm kleine Pflanzen ausm Baumarkt.
So bei Kölle und sowas gibt's sowas ja, ne, ganz gut. Oder auch in in anderen Geschäften. So und dann ähm eigentlich, nachdem ich eine Saison mal so durch hatte und so im Prinzip wusste, wie das wie das so funktioniert und so die wesentlichen äh Eck
äh so intus hatte, habe ich's dann einfach mal selber probiert. Und man braucht halt auch schon, wenn man das wirklich aus Samen machen will, braucht man hierzulande ein bisschen Equipment, dass
leider nicht ohne. Das ist zwar nicht teuer, das liegt alles im Bereich also das kann man für für für deutlich unter hundert Euro alles haben, ja? Also das ist jetzt wirklich so Hobby-Bereich, aber man braucht eben schon ein paar Sachen, um ein paar Vorbereitungen, wenn man hier auch Samen ziehen will.
Was denn so Gewächshaus oder was.
Ja ein Minigewächshaus. Also das erste Problem äh was man hat ist ähm also
ne, in in ihren in ihren eigentlichen Heimatländern wachsen Chillies das ganze Jahr über, die haben da das ganze Jahr über Sonne und viel Licht.
So, das ist hier ein Problem, ne? So, dann haben die natürlich haben die auch eine gewisse Zeit, die die brauchen, ähm wenn sie aus dem Samen schlüpfen sozusagen, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie Früchte produzieren und die dann auch ausgereift sind
So, wenn man das also hinbekommen möchte, in dem Zeitfenster, was man hier hat, muss man tatsächlich sagen wir mal im Dezember,
Spätestens im Januar, Anfang mit der Keimung. So und um diese Keimung zu machen, braucht man also muss man zum einen die Samen in Wasser einlegen.
Ähm,
Beziehungsweise, also ich mache das meistens so, ich lege sie einen Tag lang in Wasser ein, damit die sich schon so ein bisschen vollsaugen können und pflanze sie dann in Anzuchterde ein und dann brauchen die aber eine konstante Temperatur von so zwischen ja sechsundzwanzig und achtundzwanzig Grad.
Noch eine so eine Heizungslampe drüber.
Ja, ich habe eine Heizmatte drunter und dann so ein kleines Minigewächshaus im Grunde wie so eine kleine ähm Plastik
Kiste äh also mit einem Deckel und in diese Plastikkiste stelle ich dann so kleine Schnapspinnchen, tue ich ein bisschen Wasser rein, da tue ich dann die in das Wasser tue ich die Samen rein und davon habe ich dann eben für jede Sorte ein so ein Pinchen und da drunter die Heizmatte mit einem Thermostat,
Und ähm damit ich eben sicher stelle, ich habe diese Temperatur von zwischen sechsundzwanzig und 8undzwanzig Grad. Und dann sollte das so innerhalb von,
Wenn man Glück hat zwei, drei Tagen, ähm wenn's etwas länger dauert, vielleicht so 14 Tage,
selten noch länger. Bei manchen Wildsorten kann's noch länger dauern, aber eigentlich so in dem Zeitraum ähm sollte sich dann, wenn man die eingepflanzt hat, ähm,
Sollte dann sich halt äh ein Keim zeigen.
Aber du hast ja jetzt nicht vorher nochmal von deinem Kanarienvogel äh fressen und ausscheiden lassen, damit sie auch entsprechend angeraut sind.
Nee, aber es gibt manche Leute, die die machen das äh äh zum Beispiel mit Aceton oder so, versuchen die halt die Samen so anzurauen.
Ist mir zu viel Gedöns, finde ich. Also braucht man auch nicht. Ich finde, es reicht wirklich, wenn man die einen Tag lang in warmes Wasser einlegt, also auch so 82 Grad warmes Wasser.
Einfach in Anzuchterde pflanzt, das Ganze ähm konstant auch so bei dieser Temperatur hält, ab und zu mal lüftet, damit's nicht schimmelt, dann funktioniert das eigentlich ganz.
Okay, also es geht jetzt nicht primär darum, dass man einmal im Vogel gewesen ist. Das hilft nur und äh es geht aber auch ohne.
Genau, es geht auf jeden Fall auch ohne. Man man muss das nicht machen, aber es begünstigt sozusagen die Keimung, ja?
Genau und wenn die dann gekeimt sind, lässt man die halt noch also dann brauchen sie vor allen Dingen Licht, dann brauchen sie nicht mehr ganz so viel Wärme. Ich nehme die dann meistens in ein zweites Gewächshaus, was nicht ganz so warm ist, was eher so,
einundzwanzig, 22 Grad hat und genau, dann lasse ich den einfach ein bisschen weiter wachsen.
Und wenn die dann, weiß ich nicht, so eine Woche ungefähr gewachsen sind und auch so gleich kleine Wurzeln gebildet haben, dann werden die pikiert, also die
Verschiedenen Pflanzen werden dann vereinzelt und eben jeweils in ihren in ihren eigenen kleinen Pott gesetzt und in dem wachsen sie dann weiter.
Ne und dann gibt's dann nochmal einen Schritt später, dann kriegen Sie auch dann andere als Anzuchterde, also Erde mit ein bisschen mehr Nährstoffen, so nach nach weiteren vier Wochen ungefähr und kommen dann nochmal in größeren To.
Ist, wenn man die so einen dicht nebeneinander irgendwo.
Genau, also genau, normalerweise, wenn ich ich wenn ich so einen Anzuchttöpfchen habe, das ist so zwei mal zwei Zentimeter ungefähr von der oben die Fläche und dann nochmal so zwei Zentimeter hoch. Dann kommt Anzuchterde rein und da
Kann man denn in ein Töpfchen drei, vier, fünf Samen reinsetzen? So, wenn diese Samen dann keimen, dann können ja nicht diese fünf Pflanzen in so einem kleinen Pot jetzt die ganze Zeit weiterwachsen, dann würden sie auch die Wurzeln verheddern und so, man würde die hinterher gar nicht mehr auseinander bekommen. Und deswegen, also wenn die gerade mal so eine Woche alt sind
Dann nimmt man die da halt eben raus, fuhr ganz, ganz vorsichtig nie an den Wurzeln anfassen, die sollte man nicht beschädigen und ähm setzt dann eben diese Keimlinge in ihren eigenen Topf, wo die dann eben
weiter wachsen können ungestört.
Und wie lange dauert das dann, bis es so respektable.
Pflanzen sind,
Also sagen wir mal so, wenn man im Dezember anfangen dann sind die im März ungefähr so weit, dass die in so einem Ein-Liter-Topf auf der Fensterbank stehen können.
Und dann setze ich die in der Regel so nach den Eisheiligen, kann man die mal raussetzen. Ich setze sie dann, also ich
habt keinen Garten, so Balkon und macht es dann in der Regel so, dass ich halt einen,
so Töpfe habe, die irgendwie mindestens siebeneinhalb Liter sind, höchstens zwanzig, 25 Liter, das war dann schon eher selten.
Also Eisheilige ist dann so Mai.
Ja Ende Mai. So, ne? Genau und ähm,
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich setze die dann eben nach draußen und dann wachsen die eigentlich eine Restesaison aufm Balkon und dann hat man je nachdem, es gibt Sorten, die sind sehr früh, da hat man dann vielleicht im Juli sogar schon Früchte, die man ernten kann und äh bei anderen,
eben dann erst so im August, September, Oktober. Aber also bis Oktober kann man eigentlich hier ganz gut die Saison laufen lassen.
Okay und dann.
Ja und dann in der Zeit nochmal permanent eigentlich ernten. Und je nachdem wie viel Pflanzen man dann eben angebaut hat oder wie mehr oder weniger zu ernten. Also es ist wirklich sehr sehr abhängig von den von den Sorten, ne? Es gibt also hier, ich habe zum Beispiel hier eine mitgebracht,
eine Lieblingssorte von mir, die nennt sich Monkey Face, die hat so sehr lustig verdelte äh äh Früchte, hat so eine ganz schöne Intensivgelbe Farbe, ist eine anorm Sorte aus Peru,
Und ähm die hat traditionell eher wenig Früchte. Also da sind dann so vielleicht sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn dran an an einer in einer Saison.
Wenn man dann jetzt so was hier nimmt, wie diese ähm Achillemon, heißt die, diese hier, also in so eine gelbe Achiesorte, also eine Plakatumsorte.
Hier sind ja auch alle immer so eher so länglich, wie man das sich eigentlich so von Chili so vorstellt, ne, also diese diese dicke paprikaartige Form verbindet man glaube ich in unserem Kulturkreis nicht so primär mit Chili, ne?
Genau, wobei das eben viele von diesen von diesen von diesen ganz scharfen, von den chinesischen Sorten, die haben so eine Paprikaform nur eben in ganz kleinen.
Mhm wir sind zusammengestauchte Paprika.
Und diese hier, diese Achillemon, die nennt sich auch Lemon Drop, weil die ursprünglich wachsen die so grade nach oben, ja und wenn die dann eine gewisse Schwere erreicht haben, dann fallen die so runter und dann hängen die nach unten und deswegen eben Lemon Drop. Ähm genau und also von so einer Lemon-Drop, da sind an einer,
Hundert, hundertfünfzig, 200 Früchte dran, also das ist richtig viel dann, ne? Oder hier, ich habe mir noch so eine andere, die heißt Heavenaro White Bullet
Die ist sehr, sehr scharf hier, sehr klein, ganz kleine Beere, so cremefarben, gelblich,
Und ähm das ist ein kleiner, extrem dichter Busch und ich war hunderte von diesen Dingern sind da dran. Also das ist also da kann man schon schon wirklich sehr üppige Ernte haben.
Ne, also also zwischen irgendeiner einstelligen Anzahl von Früchten und einer dreistelligen Anzahl von Früchten ist da pro Pflanze und Saison alles drin.
Und was machst du da mit denen? Also.
Essen.
Also ist das für dich so der Snack zwischendurch oder hast du jetzt auch noch die passende Restaurantkultur äh dazu zugelegt und äh kochst jetzt sozusagen China und Vietnam einmal rauf und runter in der maximalen Ausbaustu.
Also ich koche eigentlich schon, wenn ich koche, ist da eigentlich immer irgendwas mit Chili dran, mehr oder weniger. So, ne? Ähm,
Also es ist jetzt nicht alles scharf, betont scharf oder so, ähm gibt auch schon Sachen, die durchaus mild sind, aber ja, eigentlich verwende ich schon jeden jeden Tag. Chili auch manchmal einfach nur so auf Brot oder so. Ähm
Was ich auch mache damit ist ähm dass ich sie trockne. Also ich habe einen Dörrautomaten,
ist auch jetzt für nicht allzu viel Geld zu haben. Es ist wirklich nicht besonders teuer und man kann damit ähm Gemüse, Obst,
Oder eben jetzt auch so Chilis, ganz wunderbar trocknen und ähm kann die also so weit, dass die,
irgendwie vier Prozent Feuchtigkeit haben oder noch weniger und danach benutze ich dann so eine Kaffeemühle, um die zu mahlen und mache dann da Pulver draus. Das ist zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit, wie man die sehr gut konservieren kann und wie man ähm.
Wie man wie man eben dann auch nachher sehr gut dosieren kann, ja, was wie viel Schärfe man an so einem Gericht dran gibt. Eine andere Möglichkeit, man kann die auch einfrieren,
dann sehen die beim Auftauen zwar nicht mehr so schön aus, aber die Schärfe geht nicht kaputt durch das Einfrieren, sondern die bleibt genauso erhalten, wie sie ist. Hm,
Und äh also deswegen geht das auch ganz gut. Und eine Sache, die ich in diesem Jahr erstmals probieren möchte, die ich selber noch nicht probiert habe, aber da bin ich kürzlich durch eine Anregung auf Twitter drauf gestoßen, ist ähm,
fermentieren. Ja, das geht auch relativ einfach und zwar ohne Zusatz,
Von äh irgendwie speziellen äh Fermentkulturen oder so, sondern es geht wohl offensichtlich nach allem, was sich so gesehen und gelesen habe, aber wie gesagt, noch nicht selber ausprobiert habe, ähm einfach durch Milchsäurebakterien, die in der Luft sind. Also man braucht nur so ein
Fermentabottich und ähm kommen ein paar Zutaten rein, Wasser drauf und dann lässt man einfach eine Weile stehen und dann fermentiert das tatsächlich und ich habe solche fermentierten Soßen schon mal probiert. Ich finde, die haben tatsächlich einen ganz, ganz eigene Qualität. Da ist die Säure, schmeckt,
Tja, wie soll ich sagen, Refine, raffiniert,
So ähnlich wie wie finde ich immer, wie die Säure von so einem Riesling oder so, die ist so perlen und ähm so ähnlich ist dann die Schärfe auch. Die verändert sich und und wird kriegt so eine ganz eigene,
Qualität ganz faszinieren.
Fermentiert direkt die die Pflanze.
Nee, die die Früchte.
Also ja also man nimmt die die Früchte als Ganzes und.
Ne, man kann die auch aufschneiden noch, muss sie natürlich vorher waschen. Kann auch andere ähm Aromaten dazu, tun, Knoblauch oder so was, ja? Und dann kommen im Wesentlichen ähm vor allen Dingen Wasser einfach da drauf.
Das heißt, die werden dann feucht gehalten, damit dieser Fermentationsprozess stattfindet.
Genau. Man hat die in so einer großen Fermentationsgärke sozusagen.
Also mit geschlossenen Systemen.
Ja, genau und muss nur einmal am Tag ähm die die Gase, die Überschüssigen einmal rauslassen.
Aufmachen und Milchsäurebakterien auch wieder reinlassen sozusagen in dem Moment.
Und dann das also das soll wo so funktionieren, dass eben die die guten Bakterien, also die Säurebakterien sich so schnell so stark vermehren, dass andere keine Chance haben. Wie gesagt, ich hab's selber noch nicht probiert, das äh wird dieses Jahr auch für mich mal ein Experiment,
Fand das äh finde das aber wirklich ganz interessant und ich habe auch dieses Jahr wieder so viel übrig, deswegen ähm ist so eine ganz schöne Idee, wie man, wie man wie man die mal loswerden kann.
Du baust also auch deshalb so viel an, damit du genug zum Verheizen hast für irgendwelche Experimente, die vielleicht auch mal nicht klappen.
Um mich so genau um mich selber unter Druck zu setzen, äh dass ich doch jetzt die irgendwie loswerden muss. Nee, einfach das passiert halt mehr so.
Ja, bei dem Wort Dörrautomat musste ich gerade so ein bisschen zucken, weil ich mir dann auch so dachte so, ach so was gibt es, aber selbstverständlich gibt's sowas natürlich auch schon in unserem äh Überangebot.
Da kann man übrigens auch total mit einem Dörrautomaten kann man total gut seine eigene Instenbrühe herstellen. Wenn du so hingehst und so was wie Sellerie und äh Möhren und so weiter, was man so typischerweise in Brühe reinmacht.
Bisschen klein schneidest, dass es ordentlich richtig ordentlich da ist und dann ähm komplett also äh pulverisierst mit so einer ähm mit einer Kaffeemühle. Dann hast du so ein eigenes instens Suppenpulver. Funktioniert ganz gut.
Das geht echt gut. Und.
Teuer, ne? So ein so ein Dörr.
Nö dreißig, dreißig, 40 Euro gibt's auch für 80 Euro, aber so ich glaube ab dreißig oder so. Irgendwie.
Und das einfach so ein Gerät, wo so ein bisschen durchgeblasen wird und.
Genau, das ist im Grunde wie ein wie eine Art wie eine Art ähm ähm Föhn auf mehreren Etagen und den bläst halt einfach nur ein paar Stunden heiße Luft über die Klamotten und ja so trocknet die dadurch langsam. Das ist ganz einfach.
Mhm.
So und so hast du jetzt hier deine Habaneros äh zusammengetrocknet. Dadurch halten die sich natürlich dann richtig lange, oder?
Genau. Also man kann diese hier haben jetzt sogar sie haben sogar glaube ich ein kleines bisschen Feuchtigkeit wieder gezogen, aber man kann die so ganz knispeltrocken machen, dass die wirklich zerbröseln, wenn man die anfasst. Ähm,
Diese hier kann man auch außen also außen kann man die hier anfassen oder oben an dem Stiel, ne. Nur wenn du jetzt innen drin also diese aufgeschnitten, also innendrin dann und,
Genau, die haben auch einen deutlichen Geruch. Das ist jetzt eine Jamaikan Hot Chocolate heißt die.
Und also ist so ein wie ähnlich wie die Scotch die es halt auch auf ähm Jamaika gibt. Ist auch eine Jabanero Variante, ist so zweihundertfünfzigtausend bis 3fünfzigtausend Scoville. Das ist so die,
Schärfe einer ist, vielleicht können wir das auch nochmal kurz erklären, weil das hatten wir glaube ich noch gar nicht.
Wollte ich jetzt auch nochmal ähm,
Also ich wollte nur mal kurz das hier mit diesem mit diesem haltbar äh Machen noch kurz zu Ende bringen und dann können wir uns vielleicht nochmal so auf den Konsum äh konzentrieren. Erstmal hier wieder zurück,
Ähm,
Also die wachsen halbes Jahr, man hat irgendwie reichlich äh Ernte, wenn man sich so ein bisschen Mühe gibt mit äh dem hm richtigen Samenansatz und Gewächshaus und Temperaturen und so weiter halt.
Mich gerade daran äh hier ähm Ron von mir, die äh hat's ja auch immer mal so,
Orchidarium zusammengebaut und hat sich dann halt auch gefragt, wie sind denn da jetzt sozusagen die richtige Temperatur und den richtigen, ne, also wie bewärmt man und befeuchtet man die, damit diese,
Orchideen auch richtig schön ziehen können und der hat eigentlich den,
Einfachsten Nerdansatz gewählt. Äh den hat sich halt einfach aktuelle Temperaturmessung aus Costa Rica übers Internet geholt und genau diese Bedingungen hergestellt,
Ja, also sozusagen gar nicht groß irgendwie fragen, was das Richtige ist. Äh man kopiert einfach eins zu eins das, was jetzt grade auf der anderen Seite des Planetens stattfindet und sorgt dann äh entsprechend dafür. Vielleicht wäre das ja auch noch mal ein Ansatz für deine Gewächshäuser, dass du dann.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich das, was man so macht im Wesentlichen, ne. Also das ist schon so, man man stellt halt die Lebensbedingungen nach, der der Pflanzen, wie die die eigentlich gerne hätten, so.
Genau, so und dann tragen die ordentlicher, weil dann dann hat man ja unter Umständen mehr als man braucht. So und Dörren ist jetzt sozusagen würde ich sagen so ein bisschen der Königsweg oder verarbeitest du dir am liebsten frisch?
Nö, dass das kein das weiß ich nicht. Das kann man so gar nicht sagen. Das kommt ja immer drauf an, die die gewinnen ja auch so wie der eigene Qualität. Man kann mit dem Dörren zum Beispiel, wenn man das ein bisschen,
zu stark macht, kriegen die so einen leicht nussiges Flavour so dazu. Das ist aber gerade mal ganz ganz interessant sein, bei manchen Sorten passt es ganz gut so. Die schmecken eh so ein bisschen erdig und da passt es dann, wenn die so ein bisschen so was nussiges dazu kriegen. Ähm,
Ich eigentlich benutze ich oft gerne ähm so ein so eine Kombination aus beidem, also frisch und getrocknet finde ich äh ähm oft nicht schlecht
Ähm wie gesagt, man kann mit den mit den Pulvern einfach relativ
das gut steuern, ja? Wie wie schärf ich das denn jetzt haben möchte und und wie intensiv ich das jetzt haben möchte. Da also Pulver sind einfach sehr gut dosierbar.
Klar frische Chilis auch, aber ähm die schmecken natürlich immer noch mal ein bisschen, bisschen anders. Ich finde auch, dass die
Pulver so meistens in Essen irgendwie ein bisschen besser durchkommen so, aber das auch nur so eine subjektive Wahrnehmung, weil kann ich jetzt durch nichts weiter belegen, aber,
Ähm nö, ich finde nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie so den den Königsweg gibt. Also Dörren ist auf jeden Fall das, glaube ich, wo die mit sich mit am längsten mithalten.
Umpulverisieren, hm,
einfrieren habe ich ab und zu mal gemacht, habe ich aber also haben nie länger als ein Jahr jetzt probiert, deswegen weiß ich nicht genau würden die sich jetzt auch drei Jahre halten, kann ich gar nicht sagen, aber ähm,
Ja, also,
Ich bin ich bin halt sehr gespannt. Ich muss sagen, also im Moment interessiert mich halt dieses fermentieren einfach sehr, aber ganz ganz spannend finde und weil ich bisher einmal so eine fermentierte Sauce hatte, die ich heute echt sensationell fand und.
Aber nicht selber gemacht hast.
Nee, nee, die hatten die hat einen Freund von mir gemacht, ähm der eben auch Cheese anbaut, aber ähm ich habe wie gesagt das leider noch nicht selber probiert, aber das ist eine Sache, die möchte ich äh sehr gerne jetzt mal ausprobieren, bin ich echt gespannt.
Nächste Nerdsteigerung,
Tee. Ähm was meine, du kannst mir ja erzählen, dass das jetzt alles von vornherein,
problemlos funktioniert halt man, wenn man jetzt erstmal so anfängt da so Pflanzenkultur zu entfachen in der eigenen Wohnung. Da geht doch bestimmt auch irgendwas schief.
Ja klar. Also
bei meinem ersten Anbau gab's natürlich auch Pflanzen, die es nicht geschafft haben, was mir dann tatsächlich in der Seele weh tat.
Äh beim allerersten Mal äh habe ich auch tatsächlich noch nicht irgendwie so einen so ein schönes äh da hatte ich das alles noch nicht so schick hier mit äh,
Heizmatte und und Minigewächshaus und so. Da habe ich habe tatsächlich mir ursprünglich mal so eine Art eigenes Minigewächshaus gebaut aus einem aus einem Umzugskarton.
Und ein paar und ein paar äh Neonröhren. Ähm,
Äh das hat auch irgendwie funktioniert, aber wie gesagt, also war natürlich noch nicht so ganz elegant. Ähm da das war dann auch nur so zum Ausprobieren beim ersten Mal, aber ebenso, dass das wächst natürlich nach und nach, ne? Aber sonst im Großen und Ganzen, also so richtig viel.
Schiefgehen tut er jetzt nicht. Also ich meine, was natürlich was ärgerlich ist, ähm als wenn man so eine Pflanze gepäppelt hat und gehegt hat und so und dann stellt man die nach draußen,
So irgendwann Ende Mai und dann kommen Anfang Juni die ganzen Schädlinge.
Und das klatscht einem unter Umständen schon mal ganz ordentlich einen Nacken, finde ich. Also da erschreckt man sich dann manchmal, wenn man das sieht. Es gibt halt die unterschiedlichsten äh Schädigungen, die Klassiker sind halt Blattläuse.
Und ähm die dann oft, wenn die da sind, dann sieht das auch sehr dramatisch aus, weil die gleichen solchen Mengen auftreten. Ähm Blattläuse kriegt man aber relativ gut in den Griff.
Also zum einen ähm was man sehr gut nehmen kann, ist Nehm-Öl,
Ja, nehmen ist äh ähm so ein Öl, das wird extrahiert aus einem aus einem aus der Rinde von einem Baum und das führt dazu, dass die dass die Fortpflanzung bei den Blattläusen unterbunden wird.
Ähm das ist aber biologisch abbaubar. Ähm insofern kann man also durchaus auch bei Pflanzen,
Von denen man später mal die Früchte essen will, kann man nehmen, einsetzen, ohne dass man sich jetzt allzu viel Gedanken darum machen muss, dass man dann später Insektizide sich in den Körper rein tut oder so.
Vom Nienbaum.
Ja, Nim oder Nehmen, ja.
Oder nehmen heißt das genau.
Und ähm,
Genau, also das ist äh kann man so macht man so eine Sprühlösung einfach mit und und ähm sprüht die Pflanze einmal richtig da mit ein, ist die richtig tropfen nass, das muss man zwei dreimal wiederholen und dann sagen wir mal, sind die Blattläuse auch nicht komplett weg, aber doch deutlich dezimiert und,
In der Regel kommen dann spätestens im Juli die Räuber und davon gibt's eben auch eine ganze Menge und das ist zum Beispiel auch also das ist eins wahnsinnig brutal.
Vögel oder was.
Nein, ich meine andere Insekten, also zum Beispiel die Larven von Marienkäfern
Den Laden vor Marienkäfern sehen aus wie so wie so kleine, schwarze Skorpione mit so einer orange-weißen Teppichfliese aufm Rücken. Und ähm eine von diesen Viechern kannten
paar 1hundert Blattläuse wegmachen. Also die sind die sind richtig brutal und die sind extrem effektiv in der Bekämpfung von Blattläusen.
Dann gibt's auch noch andere Florfliegen zum Beispiel,
oder Schlupfwespen. Ähm Schlupfwespen sehen so ein bisschen aus bisschen so ähnlich wie Ameisen, auch so schwarz, haben wir aber dann natürlich Flügel und Schlupfwespen legen ihre Eier in Blattläuse ab.
Also ich habe irgendwann mal, als ich äh äh so in den ersten paar Jahren, als ich dies angebaut habe, war ich sehr überrascht, dass ich irgendwann auf meinen Pflanzen alles so kleine weiße Gnubbel gefunden habe.
Mit so Härchen dran und ich wusste nicht, was das ist. Ich habe mich gefragt, was eine Krankheit ist oder was und habe auch ein bisschen recherchiert und habe dann festgestellt, nein,
Das sind die übrig gebliebenen Chitinpanzer von Blattläusen, die von einer Schlupfwespe gestochen wurden, was die Schlupfwespe macht, ist sie sticht die Blattlaus und legt in der Blattlaus ihre Eier ab,
klebt die Blattlaus dann an ein Blatt, dann verendet die Blattlaus und innen drin schlüpfen die kleinen Schlupfwespen und fressen diese Blattlaus einmal komplett innen leer.
Und brechen dann den Panzer auf, springen raus und fliegen weg.
Dann bleibt nur noch so eine Hülle über.
Genau und dann bleibt dieses Weiße, was übrig bleibt, ist halt der Chitinpanzer, das Haarige sind die Beinchen tatsächlich von der Blattlaus gewesen. Also schon ganz schön brutal irgendwie alles, ne?
Aber so ist halt Natur und es ist halt wirklich sehr effektiv und also ich fand das sehr interessant, zum Beispiel auf meinem Balkon jedes Jahr zu sehen, wie sich dann,
Also wie am Anfang schon diese erste Welle Fressfeinde kommt, aber da also da Schädlinge kommt und dann sich aber ganz schnell ein Gleichgewicht einstellt
Weil dann eben genauso im gleichen Maße kommen eben Spinnen, Schlupfwespen, Marienkäferlarven, Florfliegen und so weiter,
Und ähm ja machen dann den den Schädlingen den Garaus. Es gibt aber auch Schädlinge, die sind deutlich schwerer zu bekämpfen, zum Beispiel ähm Spinnenmilben,
Ja Verweben, so die ganze Pflanze in so einem mit so einem mit so einem klebrigen,
Gespinnst und die Pflanze geht dann auch einfach ein und es gibt zwar Möglichkeiten, Pflanzen, die von Spinnmilben befallen sind, zu retten, aber ich würde tatsächlich empfehlen. Also das ist so umständlich, dass sich das in der Regel nicht lohnt. Das Wichtigste ist, dass man die schnell isoliert von den anderen, damit es nicht übergreift.
Und ähm also das ist eigentlich also leider so nach also nach meiner Erfahrung immer so ein bisschen so ein Todesurteil für eine Pflanze, wenn die, wenn die von Spinnenmilben befallen ist, leider.
Auch das.
Von den anderen, dass man zumindest nur eine verliert sozusagen. Mhm.
Das äh ist mal eine ganz gute,
gute Empfehlung und dann was was auch noch typischerweise gerade in der Zeit in der man anzieht äh ähm auftreten kann ähm sind äh Trauermücken,
Trauermücken sind eigentlich in in gerade wenn man so billige Erde kauft. Das war zum Beispiel ein Fehler, den ich am Anfang mal gemacht habe. Also nicht so besonders gute Erde zu kaufen, wo irgendwie Billig Erde aus dem Supermarkt zu kaufen.
Kann ich wirklich nur von abraten.
Was heißt denn nicht so gute Erde?
Also es gibt halt tatsächlich Qualitätserde, sagen wir mal, von Markenherstellern, bei denen also die Rohstoffe, die verwendet werden, äh immer unbedenklich sind, die zum Beispiel auch
Zum Beispiel genau eben torfrei zum Beispiel. Also ich fand diese war zum Beispiel eigentlich immer sehr gut fand, so eine Erde die eben auch torfrei ist und die bei mir immer ganz gut funktioniert hat,
Neu-Dochung von von Neudorf
aber ich will jetzt auch gar nicht so Werbung für bestimmte Sachen machen. Gibt auch hier äh äh Compo und keine Ahnung, alle möglichen anderen ganz tollen Hersteller. Aber jedenfalls, also so diese No-Name-Bilder ausm Supermarkt ist keine gute Idee, denn zum einen ist die oft nicht richtig kompostiert und zum anderen ähm,
da sind oft Eier von Trauermücken drin. Trauermücken sind an sich unschädlich, die sind halt nur nervig, sind wie so Fruchtfliegen oder so, ja ähm,
Plötzlich hat man da so ein
So ein Schwarm von diesen kleinen schwarzen Viechern um seine Pflanzen rum, fragt sich, was das soll. Also wenn die schon Schwarmgröße haben, dann wird's meistens schwierig, die noch richtig in den Griff zu kriegen. Also eine Möglichkeit, mit denen man das ganz gut machen kann, den Gelbstecker,
Also diese Klebefallen, einfach Gelb ist eine Farbe, die Insekten stark anzieht. Und ähm Blüten und so, ne, glaube ich, ist auch naheliegend.
Ja, okay, nachvollziehbar.
Und ähm genau und das sind einfach das sind einfach so ähm Plastikstecker, die so mit so einer Klebeschicht äh beschichtet sind und dann bleiben die Viecher halt da dran hängen und sterben dadurch,
So, das Problem ist aber, damit kriegt man nur die erdulten Tiere,
Und nicht die äh die Larven, denn die Trauermücken legen ihre Larven in die Erde ab oder ihre Eier in die Erde ab. Dort entwickeln sich die Larven und die erdulden Tiere schlupfen dann aus der Erde und fliegen rum,
So und die kommen auch immer vor allen Dingen dann gerne raus, wenn man wässert. Also ne, wenn man gießt, dann kommen die sehr gerne aus der Erde, weil ansonsten würden die ertrinken. So, das Problem ist also, mit diesen Gelbsteckern kriegt man nur die adulten Tiere, wenn das aber schon so viele sind.
Schafft man das nicht mehr, einfach dem dem Nachschub auch Herr zu werden, ja? Und bekämpft dann immer nur sozusagen die Spitze des Problems. Und da gibt's einen ganz guten Trick und zwar ähm,
äh Nematoden. Nimatoden sind Fadenwürmer. Die kann man so kaufen als das ist einfach nur so ein Pulver, was man ins Gießwasser tut,
Damit gießt man diese Pflanzen einmal und das Problem ist tatsächlich vorbei. Also das funktioniert wirklich richtig gut. Die sind immer toten, fressen nämlich dann einfach die kompletten Trauermückenlarven weg,
Und dann hat man tatsächlich Ruhe und also die sieht man nicht, ne? Also das die sind auch so, es sind einfach ganz normale Lebewesen, die in der Erde vorkommen.
Und die stören dann aber auch nicht weiter.
Nee genau, die machen nichts unangenehmes, sie kriegen auch nicht durch die Wohnung oder sonst irgendwas, aber also der ersten dem der ersten großen Trauermückenplage, die ich hatte, bin ich dann auch tatsächlich im Ergebnis mit Nematoden her geworden. Das hat dann ganz gut funktioniert.
Okay.
Call the Nimmertods. Ähm okay. Wollen wir schon richtig zum Gärtner, ne?
Sagte ich ja vorhin, also ich habe durch meine Beschäftigung mit Chillis einfach viel über Zusammenhänge in der Natur gelernt, über,
Schädlinge über Fressfeinde, über eben die ganze Art und Weise, wie so eine Pflanze funktioniert, wie die Originellen anlegt und so und das äh finde ich also das ist so ein so ein Nebeneffekt, der mich einfach,
total freut, weil ähm ich finde es irgendwie ein gutes Gefühl, Zusammenhänge zu verstehen.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen äh deswegen sitzen wir ja jetzt hier auch.
So sieht's aus.
Ähm kommen wir noch mal zum Essen,
zum Konsum, weil das ja nun übereingang schon festgestellt haben, so ein bisschen äh,
dass äh das dünne Eis, auf dem man sich hier äh bewegen kann,
Trotz alledem ist halt irgendwie so ein Reiz. Ich versuche mich grad noch ein bisschen zu erinnern, als ich neulich diese Chilischokolade geschickt bekommen habe, ne und ich fand das irgendwie faszinierend,
Also man probiert das halt dann erstmal, wo ihr auch gleich gewarnt hier irgendwie Abermillionen von Scoville und äh nimm mal nicht so viel und so und habe dann auch wirklich nur so ein ganz kleines Stück genommen und dadurch wahrscheinlich, dass es,
Einerseits wahrscheinlich einfach mega überdosiert ist in dieser Schokolade. Das scheint ja noch mal so der extra Sport zu sein. Ist halt einfach maßlos zu übertreiben, weil es hat ja dann sozusagen nicht mehr mit irgendeiner natürlichen,
äh Anmengung von,
Äh dem zu tun, sondern da wird halt einfach so wie reingeschüttet bis das ist irgendwie knallt. So, dann haben wir ja schon festgestellt, löst sich das dann in diesen fetten äh sehr schön, das heißt man nimmt nur so ein kleines Kügelchen,
Von dieser Schokolade äh auf die Zunge, die zerläuft natürlich dann äh schnell und schon ist irgendwie der tja.
Schmerz, weiß ich nicht, ob das so die also na ja auf jeden Fall man hat der Brand ist halt einfach,
breit verteilt, ne? Schockt einen natürlich dann erstmal so ein bisschen äh weg und so ne, dann tritt natürlich auch genau diese Effekte ein, von denen du schon
auch berichtet hast so, ne, Herz äh gibt los, Serotonin arbeitet all das und es ist halt irgendwie heiß, aber,
kaum, dass man das dann überwunden hat weiß ich nicht. Es ist halt auch dann gleich so geil.
Man will doch und man will doch man will mehr, oder? Man will noch mal.
Genau und dann will man irgendwie noch mal und das ist das ist also.
Auch das ist, glaube ich, das Serotonin, oder nicht?
Das kann gut sein, was weiß ich, was es ist so, nicht? Also vielleicht ist auch nur die eine Blödheit. Aber dieser Effekt tritt halt schon äh ein, ne, dann kann man natürlich dann auch äh dann steigert man vielleicht auch noch mal so ein bisschen, ne? Auch wenn's halt irgendwie jedes Mal immer wieder so ein wilder Ritt ist.
Genau, aber das weiß ich nicht glaube, dass es relativ äh ähm menschlich oder ich meine, also warum fährt man gerne Achterbahn oder so und wenn man denkt, während man das Pferde, während man da steil irgendwie runterfällt, oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott und direkt, wenn man
fertig ist damit denkt man so und jetzt gleich nochmal ein Ritt, ja? Also bei vielen Menschen ist das.
Bei Achterbahn geht's mir tatsächlich nicht so.
Wäre gut, aber würden sich ja relativ viele Beispiele finden.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, so so sind
Menschen halt, nicht? Und also das hat sicherlich auch was mit mit der mit der Neurochemie so zu tun und die Art und Weise, wie Chillis darauf Einfluss nehmen, aber ich glaube, das ist so was, ja, weil's halt aufregend ist und das ist eigentlich, finde ich, das, was es auch spannend macht, ja? Also
Für mich ist Schärfe im Essen eigentlich immer hat so eine ähnliche Funktion wie Salz, sage ich mal, ja. Also wenn du Salz ans Essen machst.
Dann kannst du bis an die Grenze salzen,
Dahin macht das Salz das Essen einfach intensiver, die Geschmäcker stärker und wird wie so ein Kontrastmittel, was einfach die einzelnen Geschmäcker stärker zur Geltung kommen lässt, stärker ausdifferenziert.
Ein bisschen zu viel und schmeckt nur noch nach Salz und ist komplett versalzt und eigentlich ungenießbar. Bei Schärfe ist so ähnlich. Ich finde, es macht halt das alles
lebendiger, farbiger, könnte man sagen vielleicht, also einfach so
die Geschmäcker mehr so tanzen und sobald du ein bisschen zu viel davon nimmst, schmeckt's halt nur noch scharf, betäubt alles wie Knoblauch auch zum Beispiel, wenn du zuviel davon nimmst, macht alles andere platt und dann finde ich ist es halt einfach in Anführungsstrichen falsch eingesetzt.
Ja, also wenn man eigentlich einen kulinarischen Effekt erzielen will und man macht dann zu viel Schärfe rein, dann
Dann kann man essen, damit einige auch versauen. Klar, wenn ihr jetzt eine Mutprobe machen willst, dann kommt gib ihm, ja, also dann dann kannst du irgendwie nicht genug sein, aber eigentlich äh äh wie gesagt, wenn man jetzt sinnvoll mit Chilis kocht, würde ich immer sagen,
Man muss halt gucken.
Dass man möglichst also diese diese Grenze nicht überschreitet und die die Schwierigkeit dabei ist natürlich, dass sich für Schärfe auch bei Menschen eine Toleranz ausbildet. Wer regelmäßig scharf isst,
kommen Dinge gar nicht mehr scharf vor, wo andere sagen würden, oh mein Gott,
Ja, das halte ich ja kaum aus oder so. Also das ist sehr, sehr äh äh es tritt sehr stark äh einen Gewöhnungseffekt ein, der sich auch, wenn man das dann sein lässt, mit dem Scharfessen ganz schnell wieder zurückbildet.
Aber jedenfalls, wenn man eben Leute hat, die die einen Essen regelmäßig scharf und die andere nicht und man möchte für die kochen, dann ist es nicht ganz so einfach, dann ist es oft besser,
Man gibt irgendwie Chili oder so oder so eine Soße zum Nachwürzen dazu, weil sonst wird's echt schwierig, das so zu machen, dass es für alle wirklich passend ist, ja.
Das ist das Kinderbekochungsproblem, ne? Man möchte dann gerne mal ein bisschen fetziger auch mal ausprobieren und für Kinder ist das natürlich am Anfang erstmal ein totales Notsignal.
Also Kinder nehmen auch tatsächlich,
also davon geht man jedenfalls aus, Kinder nehmen Schärfe deutlich stärker wahr als Erwachsene.
Also das heißt äh ähm jetzt eine bestimmte Scovillezahl nicht jetzt nur sowieso von von dem subjektiven Unterschied, sondern tatsächlich bei Kindern ist es wohl so, dass die diese Schärfe deutlich stärker wahrnehmen und es für die halt einfach nur Schmerz ist.
Und also das kann ich als persönliche Erfahrung sagen.
Ja, weil sie Hitze, weil sie natürlich alles, äh was ihnen in Gefahr bringen kann,
Ne? Deswegen sind auch Bitterstoffe ja bei bei Kindern nicht, ne? Kinder können man nicht verstehen, dass man Kaffee trinkt so und wir immer so ja super ne und und aber Bitterstoffe sind halt genauso so ein Warnsignal für Kinder mit
das ist vielleicht irgendwas, das ist giftig, das das fasst du jetzt mal nicht an so und natürlich äh ist die Schärfe, die ja letztlich nur Hitze ist,
Zu heiß darfst du nicht anfassen. Geht natürlich in die gleiche Richtung. Von daher absolut äh.
Nachvollziehbar. Ja, würde ich auch sagen, ja.
Nur ist die Frage, wie man sich dann halt der Schärfe äh am besten nähert. Jetzt gibt's ja in diese Einheit. Scooble.
Haben wir schon ein paar Mal hier am Rande äh angesprochen. Wo kommt ihr her und was was misst die?
Ja ähm skurril ist benannt nach einem Chemiker namens Willbur Scoville,
der diese Einheit 1910 erfunden hat und zwar um eine Maßeinheit,
für Schärfe zu haben und die Scoville Zahl gibt an, wie viel Mengeneinheiten Wasser man benötigt,
Um eine Mengeneinheit Chili so weit zu verdünnen, dass man auf der Zunge keine Schärfe mehr wahrnimmt
Also eine nicht besonders präzise Skala, sondern eine, die halt sehr stark so vom vom menschlichen Erleben ausgeht. Also noch mal, wenn man jetzt sagt, ich habe zum Beispiel ein Gramm Wasser,
Oder einen Tropfen Wasser von mir aus und ich habe einen Tropfen,
Chilipüree oder so und ich tue mir dieses Ginniepüree auf die Lösung und ich mache dann einen Tropfen Wasser drauf und ich spüre dann keine Schärfe mehr.
Dann hätte dieses diese dieses Telepüree eins Goville nicht 1000 Tropfen Wasser brauche, dann eben tausend Scoville,
Und bei zweieinhalb Millionen, wie beim Caroliner Reeper, dann bräuchte ich eben zweieinhalb Millionen Tropfen Wasser um einen Tropfen,
äh Carolina Reeper püriert sozusagen ähm so weit zu verdünnen, dass ich keine Schärfe mehr spüre. Da bräuchte man eine Badewanne voll.
Okay. Verstehe. Das ist ja eigentlich äh schön plastisch, muss ich sagen.
Genau und heute macht man das aber tatsächlich anders. Heute macht man das mit so einer HPLC-Missung, also so einer Hochdruckflüssigkeitskromatografie ähm,
Und äh damit kann man dann relativ genau die Gehalte der einzelnen Kapsazinoide messen.
So und dat Junge das sagt dann natürlich den meisten Menschen einfach nichts und dieses Kuwillzahl, die ist einfach für Menschen etwas handhabbarer und deswegen nimmt man die, die gibt's zwar nur eine grobe Orientierung, aber dann man hat dann schon eine Vorstellung,
in in welche Richtung das geht, worüber die natürlich nichts sagt, dieses ist über die Art und Weise des Brandes. Hatte ich ja vorhin schon mal gesagt, also die unterschiedlichen Chilisorten brennen total unterschiedlich.
Und das kann dieses eben überhaupt nicht erfassen, sondern die erfasst eben nur so quantitativ sozusagen mehr oder weniger und ich persönlich finde aber, dass es ähm
Anu um Chillis gibt mit 70.000 Scoville. Das ist viel, viel, viel brutaler, so subjektiv vom Empfinden als jetzt zum Beispiel eine Habanero mit dreihunderttausend
So weil die Art und Weise, wie das brennt, einfach viel gemeiner ist, finde ich bei den anderen viel, ist viel beißender oder schneidender und nicht so prickelnd wie das bei den ähm Chinensesorten ist so.
Mhm. Warum hat er sich denn überhaupt damit beschäftigt.
Das weiß gar nicht ganz genau. Was jetzt da der Hintergrund war, ich weiß nur, dass er derjenige war, aber der war, sobald ich weiß, Chemiker oder Bioche.
Fahr mal in der Pharmafirma unterwegs, ja. Na ja gut, ich meine, muss ja auch alles mal äh erforscht werden, hat er sich auf jeden Fall,
Äh
Ein Denkmal gesetzt, ja, der genau.
Äh Gesetz. Sieht aber auch echt aus wie so ein totaler Naht.
Ja, also die Skurve will äh Skala so Fehler abziehen vielleicht sein mag und so wenig sie über die Qualität der Schärfe aussagt ähm ist aber auf jeden Fall,
Das akzeptierte,
Systemen, mit dem man arbeitet. Aber es gibt jetzt keine diese Kategorisierung des. Das kommt jetzt eigentlich nur so aus deiner eigenen Betrachtung heraus. Da gibt's jetzt keinerlei äh.
Keine Einheit oder keine keine äh ähm ja Kategorien oder so mit denen man das ähm erfassen würde. Das
Das ist das ist so ähnlich wie weiß ich nicht bei Wein oder so vielleicht, wenn man da dann die unterschiedlichen geschmacklichen Ausprägungen beschreibt, so bei ähnlich blumig kann man das vielleicht auch machen, wenn man äh wenn man so Chili.
Mit einer nussigen Note im Abgang. Ähm.
Schokoladig im Zweitgeschmack, ja.
Ähm aber im Wesentlichen findet das eigentlich nur so auf den Geschmacksschleimhäuten statt. Oder.
Nee, also die die Schärfe selber ist ja schon mal kein Geschmack, sondern eben eine eine.
Ja ja aber ich meine würde diese Empfindung auch woanders noch ausgelöst werden können.
Ja, leider. Also na ja, wer mal Chilis verarbeitet hat so und dann weiß ich nicht, danach auf die Toilette gegangen ist, äh äh und nicht aufgepasst hat, der hat das vielleicht schon mal gemerkt, dass er an allen Schleimhäuten merkt man das,
Also das äh ja und das merkt man auch, wenn man sehr scharf gegessen hat.
Der war irgendwann mal so ein ganz scharfes Essen beim Chinesen, das ist schon eine Weile her. Das äh ja das hatte Konsequenzen nach hinten raus, ja.
Das auf jeden Fall. Es kann auch unter den Fingernägeln kann das auch richtig unangenehm brennen zum Beispiel. Ähm dann, wie gesagt, nachdem man etwas gegessen hat und es dann wieder ausscheidet, merkt man das in der Regel auch äh sehr deutlich und also,
Man merkt's dann auch bei allen Ausscheidungen, wenn denn die Schärfe hoch genug war.
Das heißt, die Schärfe wird in dem Sinne auch nicht vernichtet.
Äh nee
Die äh äh also Reis sozusagen durch den Körper hat da so allerlei Effekte, die eigentlich ähm weitestgehend positiv sind. Also ist zum Beispiel gut für die Herzgesundheit. Es ist eigentlich äh äh gut für die ähm Reinheit der Arterien.
Solche Sache ja vorhin schon, es hilft auch gegen oder es hilft einzudämmen diesen Heliobacter Pilori, das Magenbakterium. Ähm es fördert die Verdauung natürlich. Es kann auch, wenn man also jetzt ähm irgendwelche schädlichen Darmbakterien hat, kann das auch durchaus
helfen äh wieder ins Lot zu kommen mit dem äh mit der Darmflora. Also Chillis haben eigentlich durch und durch wirklich sehr.
Also gesundheitlich sehr positive Auswirkungen sind im Übrigen auch zum Beispiel sehr vitamin C-haltig, also im Verhältnis zu ihrer zu ihrem Gewicht haben die sogar mehr Vitamin C als Zitronen beispielsweise.
Und Paprika auch, Paprika sind auch extrem vitamin C-haltig und ähm eigentlich also auch für die Zellgesundheit und so sehr gesund. Ich finde eine also mit einem der interessantesten,
Aspekte
was jetzt die die gesundheitlichen Wirkungen von Chili angeht, ähm hat man eben im Zusammenhang mit der Krebsforschung rausbekommen. Und zwar ist es wohl so, dass bei ähm Krebszellen, die Mitochondrien, also die Kraftwerke der Zelle,
auf eine spezifische Art und Weise verändert sind. Und diese spezifische Veränderung führt dazu, dass die eine ganz eigene,
haben auf Capsa Izin. Sobald also solche Krebszellen mit Capsaizin in Verbindung kommen, lösen die so ein Selbstmordprogramm aus und also das führt dann zu so einer Apotose heißt das glaube ich, also so ein so ein ähm,
äh so einen Zelltot halt einfach, ja und ähm,
Das ist gerade ein Ansatz, den man verfolgt eben in der Krebstherapie, dass man ähm eben dafür benutzen möchte, um so Tumore und so zu bekämpfen. Das
Das Problem ist wohl nur, dass das tatsächlich nur funktioniert, wenn die Zellen unmittelbar mit dem Capsaicin in Verbindung, also in Berührung kommen.
Und das funktioniert also nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie eine Pille einnehme oder irgendwie so und dann dadurch äh der.
Also man müsste sich sozusagen direkt in den Körper an die Zellen an die Krebszellen heranspritzen oder so.
Deswegen ist jetzt gerade der Ansatz, den man erforscht, dass man das halt ähm im Zusammenhang vor allen Dingen mit Hautkrebs und so Pflastern, die man halt auf den Hautkrebs direkt
Aufkleben kann quasi äh versucht zu machen,
das jetzt grade so ein so ein Ansatz, der da in der Forschung verfolgt wird und das finde ich in der Tat also ähm ist natürlich sehr überraschend auf der einen Seite, aber natürlich auch großartig, ähm dass man gerade bei so einer Krankheit wie Krebs
Und ausgerechnet über Chilis dann so einen neuen Forschungsansatz hat, ist doch eine ganz tolle Sache, finde ich.
Und äh da fällt mir ja dann auch gleich eine andere gesundheitliche Wirkung äh ein, von der ich äh selber schon mehrfach äh profitiert habe. Diese Hitzepflaster.
Ja, genau.
Sind ja im Wesentlichen auch nix anderes als äh ausgebreitete Chilischoten,
das äh richtig sehe, das heißt, wer ist schon mal so ein bisschen im Kreuz hatte?
Das kann ja schon mal vorkommen, ne? Auf einmal äh machen die Muskeln irgendwie zu und dann wird man nicht mehr so richtig grade und dann ist es noch mal besonders unangenehm, gerade weil das so ist, ne? Also das ist ja so eine so eine so eine blöde Situation, in der sich das
in der es sozusagen der Zustand sich dazu beiträgt, dass es sich selber noch mal verschlimmert oder besonders unangenehm ist und dann hilft halt einfach diese,
Diese Wärme hinzuzufügen und dann gibt's halt diese Pflaster, die man sich auf die Haut macht, die er dann einfach quasi das Kapsaicin halt direkt auf die Haut aufbringen und dann natürlich,
mega äh losfeuern und das das kann auch äh.
Das kann sehr schmerzhaft.
Das kann schon, aber na ja, ist halt eine Frage, welche was man dann eben auch aushält, ne.
Aber äh ist interessant, dass der Körper dann halt einfach auch sofort eben mit so einer Hitze, ich weiß nicht, es ist nur eine Hitze Empfindung.
Nee, das ist einfach verstärkte Durchblutung an der Stelle.
Und dadurch löst sich quasi der Krampf in den Muskeln.
Einfach weil du stärker durchblutest und dann eben dadurch Wärme produziert wird und genau, das löst dann eben den Krampf in den Muskeln, ja.
Tolles Zeug, kann ich nur empfehlen.
Ja, also also vor allen Dingen halt, ne, ähm in Anführungsstrichen natürlich, also äh ähm es ist nicht irgendwas ähm Synthetisches oder so und eigentlich, wie gesagt, solche Mittel, also auch zu solchen Zwecken, das ist auch eine traditionelle Anwendung eigentlich von Chiles.
Also äh kennt man also auch bei Naturvölkern diese diese Art der Anwendung
und eben vor allen Dingen also tatsächlich auf Wunden, um Schmerzen zu stillen, weil das ich glaube, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie diese Chemie funktioniert, aber ich glaube, das hat irgendwas mit mit Millionenkanälen zu tun, die die irgendwie verstopft werden und deswegen die
Schmerzweiterleitung nicht mehr funktioniert, aber das weiß ich nicht, müssen wir mal jemanden fragen, der sich da in Biochemie besser auskennt als ich.
Jetzt gucken mich die ganze Zeit hier schon diese Dinger äh an. Du hast ja dir sicherlich jetzt mal hier auch zur Verkostung mitgebracht, oder.
Können wir gerne tun, ja.
So, du musst ja nur sagen, wie mutig du bist. Also ein Tipp, den man geben kann, dem man also einen Tipp, den man generell geben kann, ja, ist ähm also an der Spitze, also ähm an dem Ende, wo Chillis nicht an der Pflanze angewachsen waren.
An der Spitze sind sie eigentlich immer am wenigsten scharf. Und in der Regel sind sie am oberen Ende, also da, wo sie an der Pflanze angewachsen sind, sind sie am meisten.
Weil da halt auch mehr dieser Stege sind.
Ja genau, da sitzt genau, da ist das Zentrum von dieser Plazenta sitzt da in der Regel, ne? Und ähm genau, also eine ganz gute Idee ist immer, dass man so eine Chili erstmal aufschneidet und reinguckt,
Da kann man mich auch sehen, ob die innen noch in Ordnung ist, ne, dann kann man sehen, ob die zum Beispiel, ob innen drin irgendwie einzelne Samen schwarz geworden sind, die sollte man dann eigentlich nicht mehr essen, weil das deutet darauf hin, dass die irgendwie verschimmelt ist zum Beispiel von innen. Es gibt aber, auch das muss man wissen,
spezielle Chilisorten
Die Rokotos, von dem wir vorhin schon mal sprachen, die haben von Natur aus schwarze, beziehungsweise dunkelbraune Samen. Das sieht man aber dann auch, dass das nicht irgendwie ein Fehler ist oder so, sondern die haben einfach diese Farbe und so.
Schwarze, genau, schwarze Chilisamen, also bei bei Früchten, wo sie eigentlich nicht schwarz sein sollen, da sieht man auch, dass das das sieht einfach nicht richtig aus, so, ne? Und ähm,
Deswegen ist aber irgendwann mal ganz empfehlenswert, dass man die aufschneidet und dann kann man natürlich auch, wenn man die Schärfe einfach ein bisschen reduzieren will, dann will, dass sie nicht ganz so hart zuhaut, sondern macht man halt diese Plazentawände raus,
kratzt die einfach mit einem Messer aus oder so und dann ja,
Aber wir können jetzt hier mal eine von den von diesen Achillemon, die sind also jetzt noch nicht so scharf. Also die finde ich, sind ganz gut aushaltbar mal aufmachen,
und.
Das also so eine kleine, dünne äh drei, vier Zentimeter lange gelbe typische Chilischote.
Ne und jetzt riecht man dann, die haben schon so einen, finde ich ganz fruchtigen Geruch, ne? Also ganz anders als diese hierzu, also als DJ Make and Hot Chocolate, die so einen fast wie Schweiß oder so so einen Geruch haben, finde ich.
Der Diesjährige ist auch gedörrt gewesen.
Ja, aber trotzdem, das dieser Geruch ist bei der bei der Jamaika Nordshocke immer so und diese hier ganz so crisp und Frudi irgendwie, oder?
Ja die lädt äh geradezu ein.
Ja und dann also am besten erstmal ein klein bisschen von hier unten nehmen. Mhm.
Ganz kleinen,
okay, aber man merkt sofort, da ist äh Musik drin.
Ja, aber ich finde vor allen Dingen vorne auf der Zunge da ich habe das nicht so stark hinten, bei mir ist es vor allen Dingen vorne, bei dir nicht.
So gut, ich hab's jetzt auch gerade erst mal nur auf der Zunge. Jetzt habe ich mal so ein bisschen mh so ein bisschen verteilt im Mund. Das wird jetzt eine richtige Schmatz-Sendung. Das lieben mir die Hörer immer. Mhm.
Hm. Ja aber geht doch noch. Die ist doch.
Ist noch äh absolut im Rahmen.
Finde ich auch. Also die äh das ist eine Sorte, finde ich, die Algen ist zum Beispiel gut für Salate. Grade weil die so so sind und so und dieses Frische haben genau und diese Schärfe ja nicht so overpowering ist, die ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig böse.
Stimmt, die kommen ziemlich äh sanft reingeschustert, ja. Ja.
Kann man, ja und jetzt nimmt man nur einen. Und jetzt wird das, jetzt wird's aber schon deutlich mehr, willst du merken?
Ist auch größer.
Na jetzt berge ich aber schon was,
Ja, aber doch. Hm, aber es wird also, finde ich, kommt die Schärfe auf jeden Fall. Also dieses würzige Kohl auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr durch, sonst beiß nochmal ab.
Nützt nicht so, dass ich nichts merke. Ich äh falle bloß jetzt noch nicht gleich vom Hocker. Ist so vergleichbar jetzt mit dieser Schokoladenschärfe. Ich wollte das nur gerade so ein bisschen zu ähm verorten. Weil es halt jetzt,
Kriegt man schon so ein bisschen so die Atmung, ne? Merkt man schon. Aber,
Ist, glaube ich, ist, glaube ich, auch eher so eine eine Einstellungsfrage so ein bisschen, wie man dazu steht. Also man kann ja bei so einer Schärfe auch sofort davonlaufen.
Und ich glaube, ich habe mich jetzt schon so ein bisschen dran gewöhnt, dass ähm so anzunehmen.
Genau, das hat ganz viel also die Art und Weise, wie man dazu steht. Ähm hat ganz viel damit äh äh zu tun, wie man,
Das Aushalten kann jetzt einen einen Effekt merke ich jetzt auch gerade. Den Speichelfluss der verstärkt einsetzt. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig mit dem Sprechen dann.
Apropos Schmatz Sendung.
Hier. Mhm. Ja, definitiv.
Und ähm ja also wo wollte ich denn jetzt gerade hin? Das ist jetzt das stört doch doch die Konzentration schon irgendwie, glaube ich.
Ah! Was ja, also hier sind.
Also verteilt sich äh jetzt also ich finde jetzt diesen Effekt sehr ähm Feinperlig. Also ich finde, man merkt richtig, wie so wie sich die Schärfe sehr gleichmäßig,
In so so einem so einem kleinsten Partikeln äh überall verteilt und erst so Gesamtgefühl äh anläuft,
Und ja klar Zunge meintest du ja auch vorne, ne.
Ich habe ich habe das vorne so.
Vorne ist es auf jeden Fall noch mal ein bisschen stärker zu spüren.
Und was diese jetzt nicht hat, ähm Lippen so stark, das haben halt manchmal andere Sorten sehr stark, dass die Lippen ähm extrem brennen so dabei. Das finde ich eigentlich ein ganz mögen manche Leute gar nicht. Ich finde das ganz schön. Besonders faszinierend, was ich jetzt leider.
Du hast jetzt aber schon mehr gegessen als ich. Ist ja wild.
Ja, ja, ich habe die jetzt mal abgebissen, aber ähm also wovon ich jetzt.
Ich ich nehme jetzt noch mal, ich nehme jetzt nochmal den Mittelteil, nehme ich jetzt.
Mut. Was ich jetzt nicht mit.
Mhm. Weil's irgendwie geil ist, weil's irgendwie, weiß nicht, also hat mich nicht umgebracht.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn man sich einmal, nee, sage ich ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn das einmal so da ist, das ist so ähnlich so ein Effekt wie bei,
Weiß ich nicht so Whiskey oder so. Der erste Schluck haut ganz schön rein und dann ist es irgendwann der Mund einmal so mit diesem Ganzen so ausgekleidet und den nächsten Schlucke gehen dann viel glatter runter, finde ich. Und so ähnlich ist es jetzt hier mit der Schärfe auch.
Also die kommt im ersten Moment, aber wenn die einmal so eingesunken ist, finde ich, dann kann man das ganz gut. Was was mir jetzt, was ich jetzt noch hier nicht mitgebracht habe, ist eine,
Sorte, also eine Rokoto. Hm, die haben die Besonderheit,
dass die oft einen Brand haben, der sich im Mund bewegt. Also wenn du eine Rokoto isst, dann fängt es oft hinten im im Hals an wie mit so einer heißen Kohle und dann bewegt sich das so in Wellen übern Zeitraum von 10 bis 15 Minuten,
nach vorne. Am Ende hast du hinten im Hals nichts mehr im Mund auch nicht, aber nur vorne die Lippen. Pockern so, das ist irgendwie ganz
äh ganz, ganz, ganz interessant, finde ich. Also ganz faszinierend, wie sich das dann halt so ja entwickeln kann,
Ja, jetzt ist schon ein bisschen schärfer, ne?
Ja, aber es ist geil. Also ich find's ähm ich genieße das voll gerade so. Äh weil wie gesagt, ne, wie ist das nochmal? Lemon.
Ähm Achillemon oder Arje Lemon oder auch Lemon Drop.
Achi Lemon. Also Zitronenchili sozusagen. Mhm.
Wobei also hier muss man sagen, das Zitronigste hier dran ist eigentlich noch die Farbe, finde ich. Es gibt eine Sorte, eine afrikanische Habanero Variante, die tatsächlich allen Ernstes Fatali heißt, mit Doppel I.
Und ähm das ist echt eine meiner Lieblingssorten und das ist wirklich fast, also die ist sehr scharf, also ist 500.000 Scoville, das haut schon ganz ordentlich rein und die schmeckt.
Denn jetzt gerade? Was was war denn jetzt Goville? Äh.
Ich weiß gar nicht, die haben auch so irgendwie so 70tausend, würde ich mal sagen, fünfzig, siebzig irgendwas zwischen 50 und 70tausend,
Kannst ja auch mal nachgucken eben. Weiß jetzt ausm Kopf nicht, ne? Bei der bei der Achillemon oder Lemon Drop. Ähm.
Okay. Ähm das bezieht sich aber jetzt sozusagen auf die komplette Chili und nicht auf eine bestimmte Gramm Einheit davon oder.
Ja, wenn du jetzt im Grunde hingehst und diese Chili pürierst und dann da also eine bestimmte Mengeneinheit von hast, von diesem Püree.
Dann bräuchte ich 70.000 Mal dasselbe in Wasser, damit ich nichts mehr davon merke.
Genau, genau so ist es.
Kommt ja immer noch irgendwelche Reste noch aus irgendwelchen Ecken hervor, die einen so ein bisschen überraschen. Ähm ähm warte mal. Also hier Lemon Drop.
Ja, was oder dreißig?
Ähm muss mal gucken, ob das hier überhaupt steht.
SHU ist die offizielle Abkürzung.
Also Lemon Drops werden aufgrund ihrer Schärfe bevorzugt zum Würzen von Speisen verwendet, auf der für die Schärfebestimmung gebräuchlichen Scoovilskala liegen die Früchte zwischen 15.000 und 30.0000,
einhalten.
Also doch dreißig.
Noch ein bisschen weniger. Damit sind sie zwar deutlich milder als beispielsweise Habernero Schoten, liegen andererseits ein gutes Stück oberhalb der weitverbreiteten Jalapeno. Die eigentlich so ein bisschen so als der äh Klassiker äh gilt, ne?
Genau. Die haben so fünf also je nach Sorte zwischen fünf- und 15tausend. Also es gibt unterschiedliche Jalapeno-Varianten.
Und ähm,
Genau. Aber die sind halt eher mild und die haben dann eben auch noch so einen sehr eigenen markanten Geschmack, äh der ja den meisten ja auch bekannt sein dürfte,
Jalapenos äh sind übrigens gehören zu den Chillis äh ähm zu den wenigen Chilis, die man echt typischerweise eher in der unreifen Form ist, nämlich in der grünen,
Die meisten Chilis werden eigentlich konsumiert in der Reifenform, also in irgendeiner Farbe. Also es gibt eigentlich,
so gut wie keine Chilisorten, die grün abreifen. Es gibt jetzt erst in letzter Zeit hm so ein paar spezielle Züchtungen, zum Beispiel den äh Green Scorpion,
Also es gibt so ein so ein Variante, die grün wirklich abreift, aber ähm also Faustformel ist eigentlich alle Chillis reifen irgendwie farbig ab.
Also rot, gelb, orange, braun,
So, manche sind dann zwischendurch auch noch so äh lila ja, aber das ist eigentlich auch immer eine unreife Variante noch. Genau und dann also eigentlich immer irgendein.
Aber was ist denn hier so mit diesem Peperoni, den man hier so normalerweise so als Paprikavariante äh kauft, die sind.
Ja, diese Grünen, ja genau, das die sind dann auch. Die sind unreif. Also genau wie grüne Paprika, das ist auch keine eigene Sorte, sondern einfach nur eine unreife,
So und dass die schmeckt dann halt so gemüsiger, sage ich mal, ne? Und das ist auch bei Jalapeno so, wenn die abreifen, sind die rot.
Und dann äh sind die also A ein bisschen schärfer, B aber auch ein bisschen süßer,
Ne und in dieser roten Form werden die dann typischerweise ähm benutzt, um sogenanntes daraus zu machen oder,
dass ähm einfach also da werden die über Mesquite-Holz geräuchert und ähm dadurch kriegen die dann nochmal so eine ganz eigene,
Eigene Variante kann ich auch unheimlich empfehlen, so wenn man Chili con Carne macht, äh dass man auf jeden Fall da mit reinmacht, also dieser Rauchgeschmack mit den mit den Chilis zusammen ist einfach sensationell, das ist ganz super.
Gibt so kann man, kann man als Würzpulver kaufen, kann man aber auch so in der in der Dose von La Costana zum Beispiel gibt's äh diesen ziemlich gut ähm Schiputl in Adobo.
Ach so und das wird hier äh heißt es nämlich ähm da sie so ein dickes Fruchtfleisch haben, eignen sie sich schlecht zum Trocknen in der Luft und deswegen nimmt man das Räuchern auch.
Ja das also das gibt's also es gibt auch getrocknete ähm also die werden dann erstgeräuchert, danach getrocknet und dann zu Pulver gemahlen zum Beispiel.
Aber ja, tendenziell, also um die so an der Luft einfach so zu trocknen, da eignen sich so dickwandige eher nicht,
Nicht ganz so gut, wenn man die aber jetzt mitm Dörrautomaten trocknet, ist es eigentlich voll Wurst, dann geht es auch. So, aber also ist auf jeden Fall eine ähm so eine Sache, die man also auf
Kennt man ja wahrscheinlich, mittlerweile gibt's ja auch so bei bei weiß ich nicht so, so Burritos und so, immer so und so dazu viele kennen das wahrscheinlich auch schon.
Ähm aber ich finde also zum selber kochen total geile Zutat. Also gerade für Chilli con Carne finde ich absolut unverzichtbar. Also äh mindestens so wichtig äh wie Kaffee und Kakao an Chili con Carne.
Wie Kaffee und Kakao in Chili con Carne.
Ja auf jeden Fall, hm? Das schmeckt total großartig.
Zu irgendwelchen Mengen.
Also ich nehme so Backkakao, so einen Löffel, gehäuften Esslöffel äh für einen großen Pott und ähm und halt so eine halbe Tasse Kaffee oder so,
Also aber gebrühten Kaffee jetzt kein Kaffee
man man kann auch lösliches Kaffeepulver nehmen, aber jetzt nicht einfach so Kaffeepulver, das ist nicht gut. Nee genau und das kommt da mit rein, genau wie wie eben auch und so, was nicht reinkommt ist Mais und was auch nicht reinkommt sind Bohnen. So also man braucht eigentlich für ein richtiges Chilli nur,
Tomaten, bisschen Rinderbrühe, bisschen Bier,
Kaffee, Kakao, Chillis, Chipotal, ähm Kreuzkümmel, Oregano, Salz, Pfeffer das war's.
Kein Mais. Ist das so eine europäische.
Ja, das so so Studenten, WG Chillis, so mit Bohnen und Mais. Aber so dieses Text ist also eigentlich Quatsch, ne, was hier so
äh Tellinazi, so ein Quatsch. Ich meine, es gibt tausend und eine Variante Chilli con Carne zuzubereiten. So viele Leute wie die Chili con Carne zubereiten. So viele äh Rezepte gibt's glaube ich auch. Aber dieses wirklich klassische Texas Chili ist eben,
eigentlich ähm ohne ohne Mais, ohne Bohnen, nur eben mit ganz wenig Zutaten, auch eigentlich nicht mit Hackfleisch, sondern eher ich nehme dann so Rindergulasch und man muss es halt dann lange,
Köcheln, bis es quasi so fast zerfällt und so und dann ja ist ja hier so eine.
Und vor allem viel Chili, also.
Na ja, dicke, würzige, scharfe Fleischsoße ist das einfach nachher und dann kann man das so mit ein bisschen Sour Cream oder so zum Beispiel servieren, dann kann man die Schärfe noch so individuell einstellen,
HSG dann ganz gut und dafür nehme ich zum Beispiel auch gerne so eine Mischung aus, also wenn ich so Chili con Carne mache, so eine Mischung aus getrockneten Chillis als äh erfrischen Chillis. Dann nehmen die geräucherten,
Also eben noch dazu, denn meistens nehme ich auch noch irgendwie hier so was irgendwie eine von so richtig Scharfen, also eine Habanero oder so.
Und dann eben so noch Jalapenos manchmal noch so ein paar Peperoni dazu und so und wenn man das also richtig großen.
Aber auch richtig scharf.
Schon schon ordentlich scharf, ja. Aber.
Die Schärfe verschwindet auch nicht durch das Kochen in dem Sinne, oder.
Nee genau, die die die das Capsaicin zerfällt nicht, aber dadurch, dass natürlich du dann eben Fett da mit drin hast und so und da ganz viele andere, auch kräftige Aromaten da mit drin hast,
im Mund nachher formuliert sich das dann anders, sage ich mal. Ja, also dann ist es nicht so, ich finde jetzt auch nicht ich so so Chili, was einfach nur scharf ist, habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt, das finde ich, macht auch keinen Spaß.
Generell essen wir's einfach nur scharf ist, ne? Aber ähm,
Ich finde, so äh also es darf schon, darf schon richtig Bums haben. Also es soll ja auch bei solchen Märkten das ein Chiligericht ist, finde ich. Das macht.
Ich spüre grad so ein bisschen noch so mein mein Schärfe-Echo ist. Jetzt habe ich noch so ein bisschen Schärfe auf den Zähnen noch, aber.
Weißt du, ja, ich sage ja, vorne hier so, bleibt das im Mund noch ein bisschen, nicht? Und ist so so ein so ein Nachhall äh so ein After Glow.
Schon wieder so in diesem ich will mehr.
Also wenn du wenn du wenn du also wenn du richtig richtig mutig bist,
dann wagst du dich hier mal an, diese. Das ist eine meine Ehefrau. Ich war äh vor einiger Zeit in Vietnam ähm äh in im Urlaub und hat dann hier aus dem Urlaub äh hat sie eine Pflanze mitgebracht, die heißt ähm,
dass Google Translater äh nennt es sagt also als Übersetzung dazu Chillikatastrophe.
Jetzt fasse ich gerade Mut.
Und äh und äh also sie hat mir erzählt, als sie's gekauft hat, hat sie den Verkäufer auch gefragt danach, wie das heißt und er hat im Grunde,
Chilikatastrophe so als äh so mit mit Gesten einfach nachgestellt, ja. Also auch wohl zu verstehen gegeben und also das kann ich sagen, die sehen.
Ist jetzt schon die nächste Eskalationsstufe hier in deiner.
Na, das ist schon zwei 2 Eskalationsstufen weiter, würde ich sagen.
Ich meine, da hast du noch irgendwas, was dazwischen ist.
Also da ich habe hier das ist ein italienische Variante ähm die heißt äh glaube ich sieben, was heißt,
Also das ist glaube ich so angelehnt an sieben Jahre in Tibet äh vom Namen her und äh Nebrodi ist ein äh Gebirge aus Sizilien,
Deswegen also das sieben Jahre in die Brodi heißt das glaube ich hier. So eine kleine ja nicht ganz Bären, also etwas herzförmiger, könnte man sagen.
Ist wie eine Erdbeere, ja.
Ja, genau, wie eine kleine Erdbeere vielleicht, sieht die so ein bisschen aus und ähm also die sind zum Beispiel super für so für so Pastagerichte und so mit Garnelen oder sowas so ganz äh also die ist ja auch die ist eigentlich nur scharf. Also die hat nicht so viel Eigengeschmack,
Die ist relativ geradeaus scharf. Aber also etwas, also sie beißen da etwas böser als die Achillemon. Ah, das wäre so die Nächste,
Dann käme diese Monkey Face na ja und dann die anderen, die hier noch so liegen,
Wir haben noch was vor. Nein, ich meine, muss ja nicht, du musst ja nicht, ist ja nur ein.
Nee, wir müssen's nicht durch alles durchtesten, aber wir können ja mal.
Also was ich was.
Nochmal aufschneiden.
Kinder das oder wenn wenn's wenn's vielleicht auch mal so nach Geschmack geht, würde ich diese hier mal empfehlen. Die Monkey Face, die auch sehr interessant aussieht. Ähm wie gesagt, so
Orange, Gelb, also sehr schöne, intensive Farbe und also sehr verbeult und so. Der Name kommt davon, dass also bei manchen von den Früchten, wenn man die aus der richtigen Perspektive anguckt
haben die so an manchen Stellen sehen die ein bisschen aus wie ein Schimpansengesicht.
Der ist so ein bisschen wie eine Socke, die gerade irgendwie aus der Waschmaschine kommt.
Ja, diese hier jetzt speziell, ja, genau, aber also jedenfalls, da würde ich einfach mal hier unten einfach mal so ein Stück von abschneiden und dann könnten wir das mal.
Teilen. Okay.
Ja, genau. So, dann reicht das mal rüber, bitte schön. Etwas anders.
Das riecht jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr nach Paprika.
Genau und das schmeckt auch am Essen, hat aber so ganz leichte exotische Noten, finde ich vom Geschmack. Mal probieren.
Wieder erholt und jetzt geht's gleich in die nächste Runde. Aha.
Drei, zwo, eins, fünf.
Fehler, wenn ich die jetzt besonders zerkaue oder ist das eigentlich der Sinn.
Dann wenn du ein Geschmacks und Schärfeerlebnis haben, wie es kommt.
Okay. Das dauert aber.
Ja richtig, die ist auch ein deutlich saftiger als die andere. Die war sehr crispy, die erste. Die ist jetzt saftiger, dickwandiger und es dauert ein bisschen länger, aber der Brand kann so brodeln. Von hinten.
Ist ja fies. Ich meine da denkt man, es passiert erst gar nix. Es passiert auch noch gar nichts, muss ich sagen.
Mama, mach mal weiter. Ja, das kommt schon, Mädels. Dann gebe ich dir noch mehr.
Ne ich habe langsam.
Okay. Na ich finde, also wie gesagt, das kommt jetzt viel mehr von hinten, bei mir jedenfalls.
Ja vielleicht ist sie aber nicht so konzentriert wie die andere.
Es ist ja, es brennt halt anders. Aber ich finde, also wie gesagt, das es kommt jetzt und wenn du da mehr vonnimmst, das wird schon deutlich intensiver jetzt als die erste.
Im ersten Moment noch nicht so. Ich weiß, du denkst, das also schnappt nicht so, aber das ähm ist it's a creeper.
Also es wäre dann so äh eher etwas, was man so wie soll ich sagen? Das passt dann gut auch gut ins Chili oder.
Ja, zum Beispiel, kann man aber auch so in alle möglichen anderen A ist, finde ich jetzt so, merkst du's nicht, es kommt also schon deutlich stärker jetzt durch. Also ist echt nicht.
Ich ähm weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt schon immun bin. Also ich merke schon ein bisschen was, aber.
Also ich merk's vor allen Dingen so im Rachen.
Ja, das stimmt. Es ist viel viel weiter hinten als äh vorne.
Und auch also irgendwie weiß ich nicht wie so ein heißer Atem oder so. Es ist irgendwie ja anders.
Man wird schon schon erstaunlich, ne, dass eigentlich mehr oder weniger derselbe Wirkstoff sich hier so ganz anders entfaltet.
Genau und das wird willst du bei den nächsten, also das hier das ist eine Sorte. Das Erste war eine Backartum-Sorte. Ich hätte jetzt, wie gesagt, auch noch eine Chinense, die nochmal ganz anders, aber die ist also in der Intensität sind die. Also deutlich höher eigentlich, finde ich.
Also das ging jetzt.
Das ging, aber wie gesagt, das war auch noch der Teil, wo eigentlich fast keine fast keine Plazenta da ist. Also kannst du da hier mal reingucken. Du siehst ja, jetzt fängt das eigentlich erst an dann.
Dann geht's los, ja. Verstehe.
Und deswegen also aber ich finde, es gibt einen eine ganz gute Idee schon so, nein.
Idee habe ich. Jetzt die Frage, in was wir uns jetzt hier noch reinsteigern wollen.
Also ich würde gerade sagen, wenn wir also man muss ja auch nicht übertreiben jetzt, also wenn es also was wenn du ganz mutig bist dann nimmst du einfach mal.
Die vom diese Formulierung finde ich nicht gut.
Wenn du wenn du mutig bist, aber das also wird dich jetzt nicht komplett wegflemmen aber das ist auf jeden Fall wird das einmal richtig knallen. Das ist eine Habanero White Bullet. Die ist was willst du sagen halben Zentimeter im Durchmesser?
Das wie so ein Maiskorn.
Ja, so, also die ist nicht besonders groß, ein bisschen gelblich, cremefarben,
Und ähm das sind Sorte, die ist schon ordentlich scharf. Kannst du erst mal von unten, ja? Kannst du einfach von unten mal abbeißen. Und also das dauert auch einen kleinen Moment.
Also nur die Hälfte abbeißen oder was?
Würde ich vielleicht erstmal mit anfangen. Ah mach mal.
Das Ding ist so tiny, wie kann das so gefährlich sein?
Weißt du ja noch nicht. Vielleicht sagst du ja haha, ist es ja gar nicht. Was für ein Witz für mich.
Ja ja, vielleicht sage ich ja jetzt auch gleich zehn Minuten überhaupt nix mehr. Das kann ja auch.
Bis nächstes Mal kurz unterbrechen.
Okay, probieren wir das noch mal aus. Dann ist es vielleicht auch gut.
Habe jetzt mal so das untere Drittel,
Mal gucken.
Ja? Sehe ich.
Mal ein bisschen verteilen.
Das war nix, wa? Ups, äh das das war nix, wa? Mal an, einfach mal die ganze.
Mich noch nicht so um vom Hocker. Einfach mal die Ganser, okay.
Ja vielleicht auch weil die die die anderen vorher jetzt schon äh.
Ja, ich glaube schon, man kommt so ein bisschen ins Training. Der Körper ist ja dann sozusagen auch voralarmiert und kann das dann vielleicht auch schon so ein bisschen ähm regeln, ne.
Ja, die Rezeptoren können ja auch nicht unbegrenzt feuern. So, also das, wenn, ne, wenn die einmal sozusagen schon leergeschossen sind, dann also ist klar, man dachte ich ja, man gewöhnt sich da dran, aber da müsste jetzt eigentlich schon mal irgendwie was kommen. Nein, immer noch nichts.
Dann hätte ich nämlich noch was.
Na, ich versuche gerade so die Schärfe ein bisschen zu.
Aber mach die nicht bei dir. Also das ist eher so flächig prickelnd ist so. Das ist eben typisch Chinenser. So das ist eher diese tausend Nadelstiche finde ich als äh weiß nicht, so Feueratem oder so, wie die anderen waren.
Ja all tapfer, dass äh also jetzt hier ne ja officially den Hut gezogen.
Ist beeindruckt. Also ich meine ich meine natürlich tränen einem die Augen.
Ja aber aber nee aber also da kenne ich ganz andere Reaktionen. Das muss ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen. Das ist schon.
Podcasterfahrung.
Ist schon ja, war echt der Podcast gestellt,
So.
Hoppla was war das.
Oh ja, jetzt habe ich noch so einen kleinen Spätauslöser hier erwischt. Huh na jetzt ist das auch so in den Hals reingegangen und so, da wird das dann nochmal äh.
Es ist äh brutal, ja. Die die heiße heiße Kohle im im Rachen. Das kann schon fies sein. Aber also schon erstaunlich, oder? Also für so eine harmlos aussehende kleine Beere.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also, dass die mal einmal so, zack, ja, die kann schon ganz ordentlich.
Also wenn jetzt noch in Kontrolle der Sendung bleiben will, muss ich mich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen zurückhalten. Das reicht vielleicht auch erstmal. Ähm was gibt's denn noch, was wir noch nicht angesprochen haben, was man hier vielleicht nochmal ansprechen könnte?
Na, eine gute Frage. Ich weiß gar nicht, äh ähm.
So meine Notfrage, wenn ich's nicht richtig ausformulieren kann.
Cobra übernehmen Sie. Also ich.
Also vielleicht kannst du ja noch mal ein bisschen was zu dieser äh Szene äh sagen, die sich da jetzt so herausgebildet hat, also außer dass es ein paar Leute gibt, die ähm sich damit beschäftigen und so weiter.
Ähm das ist ja äh klar. Ähm.
Wo findet die Stadt zum Beispiel.
Also gibt's da ich meine können wir das jetzt beliebig blumig vorstellen? Gibt's da schon Wettbewerbe? Da gibt's doch bestimmt auch so Zucht äh Vergleicher, weil so was schon mal irgendwie teilgenommen.
Ja, also ähm diese sagen wir mal Chilli Szene die äh trifft sich halt
zunächst mal vorwiegend im Internet, ähm wie so viele andere so fake und Nerdszenen auch und ähm,
Ich selber bin tatsächlich also vor allen Dingen erstmal über über YouTube da drangekommen und dann über so Facebook äh Gruppen
Ja? Davon gibt's eine ganze Menge. Gibt's eine Menge Leute, die sich irgendwie mit dieser Chilikultur befassen, die also entweder ähm Soßen testen oder scharfes Essen testen und da Videos von machen oder Blog-Artikel drüber schreiben.
Ähm es gibt viele grower, also Leute eben die anbauen und dann sich über den Anbau austauschen und natürlich ist sie auch so ihre Ergebnisse gegenseitig zeigen und so weiter.
Und ähm,
Und grade war so die grower angeht, da gibt's auch relativ viele ähm Boards, also Hot Pain zum Beispiel ist so ein, es gibt aber eben auch eine ganze Reihe anderer ähm und äh bei diesen Boards noch viel mehr eigentlich als bei den Facebook-Gruppen,
Ähm gibt's wirklich so eine eingefleischte Community. Das hat was sehr familiäres oft und die treffen sich auch relativ regelmäßig. Ähm gibt zum Beispiel hier äh zweimal im Jahr aufm Tempelhofer Feld ähm so ein Treffen zum Beispiel von diesem Hot Paint-Forum.
Genau ähm Berlin-Tempelhofer Feld und ähm also eigentlich in der Regel einmal im Frühjahr einmal im Herbst, also im Herbst gibt's dann mal Erntedankfest und da bringen eben viele Leute auch ihre selbstgemachten Chiliprodukte mit, ähm alles Mögliche,
Marmeladen oder Soßen oder,
weiß ich nicht, Brotaufstriche oder was auch immer. Ähm viele bringen auch Teile so ihre Ernte mit, also da gibt's äh
teilweise grower, die wirklich wahnsinnig gute Ergebnisse ähm haben und äh dann auch andere daran teilhaben lassen.
Da werden dann eben auch viele mal so ähm Früchte getauscht oder Samen getauscht und so, eben alles, was so das Chilli-Nerd Herz erfreut, sage ich mal.
Und ähm,
Ja, also das äh da war ich eine Zeit lang auch mal aktiv letzten Jahre so etwas äh etwas weniger, einfach weil ich da weil ich da mit anderen Sachen beschäftigt war, aber ähm,
Ja, so im Großen und Ganzen, das eigentlich schon äh wie gesagt, sehr familiäre sehr, sehr, sehr nette ähm Szene so von.
Leuten, die sich eben mit mit diesen ganzen Thematiken befassen.
Also und auch wie gesagt im im Internet äh recht einfach zu finden. Ich finde so generell sagen wir mal der Ton so in den Facebookgruppen,
Und so den finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen offener und und da ist mehr so eine Art Willkommen Sch
da als teilweise in dem Board, in dem Boards ist das manchmal so, dass da schon dann so Leute, äh wie soll ich sagen, mit so gewissen Grundanforderungen hier, wenn du hier ohne Fotos von deinen Sorten brauchst du hier gar nicht anzukommen oder so. Also manchmal ist der Ton da so ein bisschen komisch, finde ich.
Ja weiß ich nicht genau eben genau,
Also das ist halt so und dann da davon darf man sich nicht unbedingt abschrecken lassen,
aber also es gibt da finde ich schon eine ganze Menge Möglichkeiten und ich sage mal, die meisten, so die ich kennengelernt habe von den von den Chilileuten, auch grad so aus Deutschland, die die freuen sich total, wenn sie Gleichgesinnte treffen und sind dann auch mal gerne bereit, irgendwie mal
Samen zu verschicken. Also er ist nicht wenn da, weiß ich nicht, 1hundert Leute auf einmal ankommen und alle Samen und Saatgut haben wollen, aber,
Also so, wenn man, wenn man so jetzt da, wenn die merken, man will sich da jetzt mit befassen und so, da sind viele sehr, sehr hilfsbereit, muss ich sagen. Und das, ich fand das immer ganz angenehm und deswegen habe ich das immer
Sehr sehr gerne gemacht hat.
Wird denn da auch viel gekocht.
Ähm ja schon klar. Also das oft gibt's auch so Berührungen zu so anderen sagen wir mal Lebensmittelszenen. Also viele von denen sind auch Wurster. Also sie machen ihre eigene Wurst zum Beispiel.
Auch mit Chili oder stellen halt ihre eigenen Soßen her. Und das geht ja dann da kann man auch ganz wunderbar experimentieren, gerade wenn man dann so eine größere Ernte hatte oder so und du hast da irgendwie ein paar hundert Früchte rumliegen, aber was willst du damit machen, ja
Eben, dann kann man ja ruhig mal ein bisschen rumprobieren und so mit Soßen fermentieren, wie gesagt, ist auch noch so eine Möglichkeit ähm werde ich dieses Jahr auch mal gerne machen.
Und,
Sagen wir mal Kochvideos jetzt so äh sieht man nicht so häufig. Man findet so auf Blogs dann schon eher Anleitungen, was man auf Video Entschuldigung, Moment mal.
Wir stehen hier ordentlich unter Feuer und so. Mir mir brennt's jetzt mittlerweile auch am Auge, weil und in der Nase, weil ich mich natürlich da jetzt auch äh äh eingeölt habe mit.
So direkt äh Erfahrung machen wir mit der Antwort zu den Schleimhäuten noch mal. Ähm,
Genau, also was man an Videos eigentlich viel findet, sind sind ähm vor allen Dingen so ähm
Soßentests oder halt so wirklich Chilitests. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt heute noch so, ich war mal ein paar Jahre lang war das mal sehr, sehr in, findet man auf YouTube auch immer noch und da gibt's auch ein paar Leute, die sich da besonders hervorgetan haben, sagen wir mal. Ähm,
mit mit mit solchen Chilitests, ne, die dann so ganze Schoten essen, so was äh findet man da mehr. Und die Faszination ist dann eben zum einen, dass man so ein bisschen abschätzen kann,
wie heftig das Ding jetzt wirklich ist, was er da gerade isst und dann auch also es gibt Leute, die leiden einfach schöner als andere.
Ich habe mir mal so ein, zwei Videos angeschaut und das ist schon wow, also äh man merkt, dass die Leute durch einiges äh durchgehen. Mhm.
Ja auf jeden Fall. Also da gibt's auch Sachen dabei, die finde ich ähm also The Don't Drives at Home, kann man nur sagen.
Ja ja auf jeden Fall.
Solche Sachen. Also alles, was über eine Million Scoville hat, ist einfach nur noch schmerzhaft, finde,
Also es gibt so so die Grenze ist eine ähm Buttdiologie oder Nager heißt die, eine indische Sorte, die vor, ich weiß nicht, fünf, sechs Jahren galt die mal so als die die schärfste Chili der Welt.
Hat so in etwa 1,1 Millionen Scoville und hat die bösartige Eigenschaft, dass äh sie halt, wenn man sie isst,
Ist sie schon scharf und wird dann aber über einen Zeitraum von 10 bis 15 Minuten immer schärfer,
Und man hat wirklich das Gefühl, das hört nie wieder auf. Und das ist schon ziemlich anstrengend, sage ich mal. Und ähm also ab eine Million Scoville, wirklich ist es einfach nur noch purer Schmerz. Selbst, finde ich, wenn man geübt ist, tut es dann einfach nur noch weh.
Und ähm,
Das äh äh weiß ich nicht. Kann ich nicht empfehlen. Also um mal zu illustrieren, wie scharf das ist, also in Indien benutzt man die äh Botologia vor allen Dingen ähm um Elefanten zu verscheuchen, indem man die
Entweder diese Früchte einfach auf die Weidezäune schmiert,
Und der Geruch ist halt so intensiv, dass die Elefanten anders als bei nicht präparierten Weidezäunen sehr verumdrehen und weglaufen und nicht einfach so drüber weglaufen und die Felder zertrampeln. Eine andere Möglichkeit ist es einfach, diese Pflanzen zu nehmen,
Auf einen großen Haufen zu legen und anzuzünden und äh dieser Rauch ist halt derart beißend, das sind auch die Elefantenreise ausnehmen und man benutzt äh in Indien die Butchologia auch, um biologische Waffen herzustellen.
Also das ist äh ähm so also Pfefferspray, Granaten und solche Sachen. Das ähm,
Ja, ist ziemlich äh also ist ziemlich aggressives Zeug so und dann äh da da hört dann finde ich also jetzt so beim Essen und so auch der Spaß auf. Das kann man so aus Novalty-Gründen mal anbauen, weil einen das interessiert und so.
BH UT und dein neues Wort Jolokia.
Ah ja, okay. Mhm, habe schon. Gut.
Ey Jolo, Alter. Wahrscheinlich. Komm einfach mal essen Yolo.
Oh Mann. Okay. Chinense.
Genau und das äh genau genommen eigentlich eine Chinense Protessens Mix wahrscheinlich, also hat so genetische Anteile auch von von beiden und ähm ja wird auch Ghost Chili genannt oder Geister-Chili ähm ist aber wohl eine Fehlübersetzung.
Also eigentlich, ich glaube, Boot ist irgendwie italienisch äh Italienisch, ist ja indisch und bedeutet äh Geist, aber eigentlich ist es die ja und das ist dann die Chili aus Butan. Heißt, glaube ich, einfach nur Chilli.
Ja.
Okay, das ist im Prinzip hier so der aktuelle Platz 3 der Schärfen, dann gibt's die von dir erwähnte Trididad Scorpion und dann halt diese Carolina Reeper, genau und da habe ich glaube ich irgendwie so ein Video gesehen, wie sich das jemand irgendwie gegeben hat.
Auf jeden Fall. Und also die Scorpion, also ist ist eine spezielle Version der Trainee Lead Scorpion, ähm die ja, das ist auch habe ich auch schon mal angebaut. Ähm,
Ist auch eine extrem, also wirklich eine sehr sehr extrem scharfe Sorte. Aber also kommt also noch nicht ran an an die Caroliner Reeper, die ist,
Die schlägt wirklich alles.
Hast du dir auch schon mal.
Yeah, sowohl angebaut als auch äh probiert. Allerdings, also ich habe die dann getrocknet und das waren so drei
Körnchen von dem getrockneten Pulver auf die Zunge getan. Es hat sich angefühlt, als hätte ich mir Alienblut auf die Zunge ge
drauf zu sage mal komplett durchgeschmolzen. Also das ist schon das äh ist wirklich das fühlt sich an, als wenn einem einer so mit irgendeinem,
Gerät in die Zunge kneifen würde oder so was schon also punktuell und sehr schmerzhaft.
Kann man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie es dann ist, wirklich in die komplette Schote reinzubeißen.
Kann ich mir auch nicht, weiß ich auch nicht. Wie wie man das macht. Also ich bin auch immer wieder beeindruckt, ich habe einen Bekannten aus England, der auch solche Videos macht und der also ähm von diesen Butgelokias zum Beispiel schon mal drei auf einmal gegessen hat,
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das macht, keine Ahnung. Also das ist aber der ist auch also ist auch ein Ausnahmefall.
Ja, man muss es ja auch nicht unbedingt immer gleich übertreiben. Ich finde das auf jeden Fall schön, dass das irgendwie so eine so eine äh äh nützliche,
Sportart ist, weil wir haben ja nun schon gehört, Chilis sind ja durchaus auch der Gesundheit zuträglich. Nicht nur was Vitamin C und Bakterienbekämpfung betrifft, sondern einfach nur hier,
ne, äh mal ordentlich die Nase freikriegen, ist ja auch manchmal schon mal ganz hilfreich.
Also na ja, weiß nicht, wenn man jetzt, wenn man jetzt so eine Verstopfung äh in der Nase hat, also wenn man jetzt eh grad eine Erkältung hat, kriegt man das damit bekämpft. Ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert.
Nee, also es die Säfte fangen halt an zu fließen, sage ich mal, ne. Also man kann, ja, also man hat einen der der Schleim geht ab, aber dadurch also die Krankheit bekämpft man dadurch jetzt, glaube ich, nicht um.
Nee, klar, weil einfach um mal frei äh atmen zu können, nimmt man ja sonst also quasi Nasentropfenersatz, ne.
Genau, das kann man schon, dass das funktioniert. Ich finde das jetzt auch gar nicht also ich finde das auch ganz angenehm. Auch auch zum Beispiel im im generell im Winter so ähm heiße Zitrone mit Ingwer und und Chili ist zum Beispiel auch ganz wunderbar so für die Atemwege und so. Also man kann sich da
in vielerlei Art und Weisen was Gutes tun.
Einmal richtig durchspüren. Ja, Volker, wir haben's jetzt glaube ich äh ganz gut umrissen, oder?
Ja, ich würde auch sagen so, ich meine, was was vielleicht nur eine Sache, die die man noch loswerden kann,
Also ähm wenn Leute gerne scharf essen, ne, dann ich würde mal immer drauf gucken bei den Produkten, ob da irgendwie jetzt nur Aroma oder Chiliextrakt oder Paprikaaroma oder so was drauf ist ähm,
Äh drinnen ist meine ich, denn also das bedeutet eigentlich immer,
Dass man einen dass man Extrakt zugesetzt hat und das ist in ganz vielen Soßen so und in viel so so Produkten, die jetzt irgendwas mit Chili haben so, da ist dann gar nicht wirklich Chili drin, sondern eigentlich nur irgendein Capsaicine-Extrakt,
Extrakte, wenn man die mal pur probiert hat, ja
Das schmeckt nicht wie irgendwas, was in menschlichen Körper reingehört. Das hat wirklich, das hat so die Qualität von Batteriesäure und hat einen Brand, der einfach völlig eindimensional ist. Also da der der dem fehlt komplett diese Komplexität, die eben durch diese,
12 unterschiedlichen zustande kommen. Das hat Extrakt überhaupt nicht und ähm.
Versuche immer dafür einzutreten, dass man einfach so Extraprodukten keine Chance gibt, weil das weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, klar, wem's gefällt, aber ich selber finde immer,
also das hat so wenig mit dem zu tun, was Chilis halt wirklich interessant macht, ja? Also diese Komplexität und diese Varianz diese,
Einfach diese unglaubliche Bandbreite und ähm ich finde es immer so schade, wenn wenn das dann gleichgesetzt wird. Mit Höf brennt halt heftig so. Das ist so,
So eine Verkürzung, die ich so schade finde. Und ich fände das halt ganz schön, wenn wenn sozusagen also ja, mehr Leute das
verstehen würden, dass da halt eben viel viel mehr gibt als einfach nur als einfach nur Schärfe und dass das echt so eine komplette kulinarische Welt für sich selbst ist, also mit,
allen möglichen ähm Parametern und Kriterien, die es da so ähm zu kennen und zu zu wissen gibt,
Das das finde ich äh ganz schön, wenn wenn sich da so also sozusagen in dieser Richtung Chilikultur noch deutlich weiter breit machen würde.
Und passe auch ganz gut zur urbanen Hobbygärtner äh Kultur, die sich ja ohnehin so ein bisschen äh breit macht so in unseren.
Ja auch das kann ich auch nur also aus eigener Erfahrung sagen wirklich,
unheimliche Bereicherung finde ich das und eine ganz große Faszination eben die die diese natürlichen Zusammenhänge zu verstehen, auch in so einer komplett durchzivilisierten Umgebung eben sich mit,
Noch solchen solchen natürlichen Vorgängen zu befassen und diese Möglichkeiten, die hat man eigentlich fast immer, weil also fast jeder hat irgendwie einen Balkon, man kann Chilis auch ohne Weiteres auf der Fensterbank anbauen.
Die müssen also gar nicht draußen. Die mögen sogar eigentlich in der Regel lieber gleichbleibende Umgebungsbedingungen.
So und was es eben auch gibt, was ich auch ähm ganz großartig finde,
Sind solche Projekte wie hier in Berlin beispielsweise äh die Prinzessinnengärten. Das sind so offene Gärten, Bürgergärten, könnte man sagen und auch da habe ich mal ein größeres Chiliprojekt gemacht in den Prinzessinnengärten, so mit über 100 Pflanzen, über 70 verschiedene Sorten, draußen in hoch B
und äh in einem Gewächshaus angebaut und ähm also ganz äh irgendwo einfach um mal zu zeigen, was es so alles gibt, ja und und ähm,
So was finde ich auch immer ganz ganz toll, wenn wenn Leute eben zu sowas beitragen und wenn's überhaupt solche Projekte gibt, dass dann Menschen, die auch eben in der Stadt,
Leben oder sogar da aufgewachsen sind, einfach mal so in Berührung kommen, ne? Mit äh mit mit
Natur, mit Pflanzen, mit der Frage, wie funktioniert das eigentlich alles, wo kommt eigentlich unser Essen her und warum sind die Dinge so, wie sie sind und das äh ja, deswegen finde ich ähm ist was unbedingt Förderungswürdig und bedürftig.
Da und wo wir jetzt irgendwie so äh in in Windeseile auf den nuklearen Holocaust zu rein reiten so sollten wir uns schon mal überlegen, wie wir denn wieder von Anfang an anfangen und dann sollte es auch nicht so lange dauern, bis wir wieder ordentlich Schärfe im Maul haben.
Die Koreaner essen ja besonders gerne scharf, habe ich gehört.
Oh Gott, das ist ein Zeichen.
Miep, Miep.
Volker, ich sage vielen Dank.
Ja, sehr gerne. Danke für die Einladung.
Ja und das war's mal wieder hier. Ein CRE äh ich melde mich bald wieder.